Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim
Britlaff und ich sage Hallo zur 211.
Ausgabe von UKW.
Und ja, heute wollen wir ein weiteres Mini-Update zum Krieg in der Ukraine liefern,
aber auch mal ein bisschen mehr World Politics anzuschauen.
Ihr werdet es ja mitbekommen haben, 2026 startet enorm durch und wir haben so
ein bisschen das Gefühl gehabt, da passiert jetzt gerade wieder mal so viel.
Da warten wir mal nicht so lange. Wir hatten die letzte Sendung am 23.
Dezember letzten Jahres, also jetzt nach gut zwei Wochen, legen wir nochmal
nach. Genau und das mache ich wie immer mit Pavel. Hallo Pavel.
Hallo.
Und ja, wir haben uns ein paar Dinge aufgeschrieben und wollen uns vor allem
mal so ein paar Gedanken machen.
Mit anderen Worten, wir reden kurz über den Krieg. Wir schauen natürlich dann
auf die Ereignisse in Venezuela und was sonst so auf den Weltmeeren noch so passiert.
Was das für die Gesamtsituation vielleicht bedeuten mag, was so als nächstes kommt.
Mal schauen, ob es noch ein paar andere Krisen gibt, die wir noch ansprechen.
An Krisenmangels ja nicht.
Für so einen Krisenpodcast wie UKW auf jeden Fall genug Futter.
Ja, aber wir versprochen, erstmal einen Blick auf die Ukraine.
Da gab es natürlich jetzt vor allem sehr viel Betrachtung auf,
wie ist denn dieses Jahr jetzt gelaufen?
Also was ist denn eigentlich passiert? Ist denn eigentlich irgendwas passiert?
Beziehungsweise,
Wie kann man das, was im Krieg passiert ist, über den Zeitraum eines Jahres
bewerten und welche Trends zeichnen sich da ab?
Ist immer ein bisschen schwierig mit Zahlen, aber ich denke,
wir haben in diesem Jahr wiederum gesehen, Erstens,
Russland kommt zwar hier und da auf dem Feld voran.
Russland fügt auch weiterhin der ukrainischen Bevölkerung große Schmerzen zu
durch die Angriffe auf die ganzen zivilen Ziele.
Aber Russland erreicht auch nicht auch nur im Ansatz die eigentlichen Kriegsziele.
Also wenn sie versuchen so weiterzumachen, dann ist es absehbar,
dass das nie was werden wird.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl, was sich bei allen
Beobachtern einstellt, dass es eigentlich ein bisschen bergab geht mit dem russischen Effort.
Also es gibt hier wieder Schwierigkeiten mit Zahlen, aber man meint,
man sieht die Einschätzung, sagen wir es mal so,
dass es Russland mittlerweile noch nicht mal mehr gelingt, die Verluste auf
dem Schlachtfeld durch Neurekrutierungen zu tun.
Reinzuholen. Also es ist irgendwo so bei 400.000 Personen im Monat,
das muss man sich mal vorstellen, also 400.000 Personen der russischen Armee,
die sie ranholen müssen, um ihre Verluste auf dem Schlagfeld auszugleichen.
Also über 1.000 Leute, die entweder direkt getötet werden oder zumindest verletzt
werden oder aus irgendwelchen anderen Gründen aus dem Dienst scheiden.
Mit anderen Worten, es gelingt Russland jetzt auch nicht mehr mit der Power
des Personals in irgendeiner Form den Druck zu erhöhen.
Und dazu kommen natürlich die ganzen anderen Dinge, die wir schon mehrfach berichtet haben.
Die Panzer gehen ihnen aus, die gepanzerten Transporter gehen ihnen aus,
die Lastwagen gehen ihnen aus.
Es geht ihnen eigentlich alles so ziemlich aus. Und gerade auch in den letzten
Wochen und Monaten gab es ja wiederum gesteigerte Verluste auch im Flugzeugbereich.
Also es sind einfach wieder viele kritische Systeme getroffen worden, sehr viel Luftabwehr.
Und klar, es gibt bestimmte militärische Bereiche, die haben noch viele Flugzeuge,
die haben noch viele Abwehrsysteme, aber sie müssen auch immer mehr verteidigen.
Also sie müssen ja nicht nur den Bereich verteidigen, wo sie jetzt die Truppen
in die Ukraine geschickt haben,
sondern in zunehmendem Maße auch noch ihr gesamtes Hinterland und da die Ukraine
also mittlerweile bis zu 1000, 1500 Kilometer weit in das Land hinein zielt und alles angreift,
also nicht nur die Ölinfrastruktur,
sondern eben auch Fabriken aller Art,
Strominfrastruktur, Kraftwerke etc.
Wird es einfach schwierig und Russland ist nicht in der Lage,
da so richtig nachzuliefern.
Das ist zumindest der Eindruck, den wir haben.
Und unter russischen Mail-Bloggern, so scheint man mittlerweile auch an dem
Punkt zu sein, dass man erkennt,
dass die ursprünglichen Kriegsziele, ja halt zum Beispiel die gesamte Schwarzmeerküste
und Odessa und so mit zu besetzen,
unrealistisch geworden sind.
Und dass man jetzt quasi schon bereit wäre, sich nur mit dem Donbass zufriedenzugeben. Also das...
Was jetzt offiziell Russland mal zu Russland erklärt, wurde dann auch komplett
unter Kontrolle zu haben.
Und Luhansk.
Ja und Luhansk, dass man die Kriegsziele jetzt dahingehend reduziert hat.
Aber selbst diese Ziele sind nicht realistisch erreichbar.
Aber interessant ist, dass man jetzt diskutiert,
ob man, oder die Hardliner befürchten,
dass der Krieg jetzt eingefroren werden könnte, ohne die gesamte Ukraine jetzt
sich untertan zu machen, was auch immer das heißt.
Also mit Teile besetzen, annektieren und den Rest der Ukraine dann wieder von
einem russlandfreundlichen Regime verwalten zu lassen.
Das ist so ein bisschen das Kriegsziel und das scheint jetzt aber auch nicht erreichbar zu sein.
Aber bereits das stellt halt ein Horrorszenario für eben viele russische Hardliner
dar, dass der Krieg eventuell bald aufhören könnte.
So diese Befürchtung macht sich breit und dass das ein Riesenfehler sein könnte.
Einer der Gründe, warum sie so lautes Wehklagen machen, ist vor allem dieser
glaube ich von uns in der letzten Sendung auch schon geschilderte Vorstoß der
Ukraine auf die Stadt Kupiansk die ja ein relativ,
wichtiger Verkehrsknoten ist und die Ukraine ja in der Rakiv-Gegenoffensive,
zurückgewonnen hat vor ein paar Jahren.
Jetzt ist es halt den Russen kurzzeitig gelungen in die Stadt einzudringen,
wurde aber jetzt nicht nur,
Aus der Stadt verjagt, sondern offenbar, und da ziehe ich mich jetzt vor allem
eben auf diese Berichte dieser Militärblogger, so hart zurückgeschlagen an dieser Stelle,
dass auch mittelfristig überhaupt nicht daran zu denken ist,
da wieder in die Gegenoffensive vorzugehen.
Also da scheint die Ukraine auch jetzt durch eine leicht geänderte Änderung
der Taktik in der Lage zu sein, immer mal wieder so Schmerzpunkte zu setzen,
wo sich dann zeigt, dass dann die russische Offensive auch schnell zusammenbricht.
Während man es eben auf der Breite der Front immer dieses,
ja wir tauschen Land gegen Zeit, also wir lassen euch mal wieder ein Feld vorrücken,
da müssen wir jetzt hier nicht irgendwie unsere Soldaten für umbringen.
Um jetzt dieses eine Feld noch zu sichern, sondern wir ziehen uns einfach wieder
ein bisschen zurück. Wir haben da noch genug Feld.
Und jeder Meter, den ihr euch so teuer erkämpft, und ich glaube,
das ukrainische Verteidigungsministerium hatte zuletzt auch,
glaube ich, die Zahl gesagt, dass so die Verlustrate derzeit so sieben zu eins ist.
Also sozusagen für jeden gestorbenen ukrainischen Soldaten gehen halt irgendwie
sieben russische drauf,
immer noch zu viele in der Verteidigung, aber das ist halt,
das klingt auch nicht unrealistisch, das ist ja eigentlich in den typischen
Verteidigungssituationen ohnehin so, dass der Angreifer einfach mehr zu leiden
hat, aber das ist halt in dem Moment, wo sich die Russen nicht weiter verstärken können,
natürlich in jeder Hinsicht deadly.
Ich meine, rein was die Bevölkerung angeht, könnten sich die Russen,
sagen Verluste von 3 zu 1 leisten, weil die haben halt einfach die dreifache Bevölkerung.
Aber insofern alles, was besser ist als 3 zu 1, stärkt dann effektiv die Russen und alles,
was schlechter ist als 3 zu 1 ungefähr,
schwächt sie also relativ zur Ukraine.
Und ja,
ansonsten, ich meine, die Russen haben es ja auch mal versucht,
ein paar Mal mit dann gepanzerten Truppen, also dem Panzern und...
Infanterie, Fighting Vehicles, konzentriert Durchbrüche zu versuchen,
so mit bis zu 30 gepanzerten Fahrzeugen gab es da einen Versuch und er ist komplett gescheitert.
Also ich glaube zwei Drittel der Fahrzeuge und Panzer, die sie da eingesetzt
haben, wurden dann im Wesentlichen aus einer Kombination aus Drohnen,
aber auch Artillerie einfach zerstört.
Da gibt es halt Bilder. Ich meine, es ist nachvollziehbar, dass man denkt, okay,
jetzt die Ukrainer sind dünn verteilt, was weiß ich, mit einer Handvoll Leute
auf vielleicht ein Soldat pro 100 Meter Frontlinie oder so.
Da würde man ja denken, dass man dann mit so einem gepanzerten Vorstoß da vielleicht
durchbrechen könnte, aber dem war nicht so.
Die Ukraine haben halt auch gesehen, dass da was kommt, weil heutzutage kannst
du einfach auch nicht 30 Fahrzeuge heimlich irgendwo versammeln,
ohne dass das entdeckt wird.
Und haben dann, wie es so üblich ist.
Haben dann schon die entsprechenden Ziele für die Artillerie markiert auf Knopfdruck,
dass sie noch nicht mal die Koordinaten eingeben müssen.
Sondern wissen, okay, wenn der Trupp jetzt dort vorbeikommt,
das ist jetzt Koordinatenset C und dann, ja, gib ihm.
Und ich weiß nicht, wie sie es machen, aber sie haben da auch jede Menge Fahrzeuge,
also Panzer mit Artillerie in der Bewegung getroffen.
Ja, das ist, also meiner Meinung nach geht das nur mit auch smarten Geschossen,
die entweder per Infrarotmarkierung,
dass da eine Drohne ist mit einem entsprechenden Infrarotlaser,
der dann entsprechend das gepulste Licht mit dem Code aussendet,
sodass die dann anfliegen können.
Oder dann gibt es halt diese deutsche Munition,
diese deutschen Smart-Granaten, von denen wir auch erzählt hatten,
die dann von oben ankommen, in der Luft explodieren und dann zwei Granaten selber
per eigener Intelligenz sich das teuerste Ziel suchen oder das,
auf was sie programmiert worden sind und dann darauf lossteuern.
Also anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären, dass sie halt da Panzer per Artillerie während der Fahrt.
Und sie machen es ja nicht nur mit Artillerie, sie machen es natürlich auch
mit Drohnen, sie machen es mit Minen, Minen, die vielleicht auch von Drohnen gesetzt sind.
Und sehr verbreitet sind jetzt auch so Drohnen, das machen ja die Russen auch,
so Drohnen im Wartezustand, die dann einfach schon mal neben den Straßen geparkt
werden und die dann automatisch aktiviert werden in dem Moment,
wo Fahrzeuge vorbeikommen und die dann vielleicht mittlerweile auch schon automatisiert
treffen. Das weiß ich jetzt nicht so ganz genau.
Also es gibt einfach eine Vielzahl der Möglichkeiten und der technische Fortschritt,
den die Ukraine jetzt mittlerweile dort zur Schau stellt, muss man fast sagen.
Der ist so weit gedient, dass sie eben in der Lage sind, mit sehr wenig Personal
und dementsprechend mit sehr wenig Verlusten, die Front auf ganzer Breite weitgehend zu halten.
Und es ist ja nicht nur jetzt die Situation in Kupiansk, sondern es ist ja auch
genauso in Pokrovsk, also die Stadt und Myrnorath, also diese Doppelstadt,
die jetzt schon seit einem Jahr der Untergang vorhergesagt wird.
Ich meine, sieht nicht gut aus, aber auch dort ist es nicht gut aus.
Kaum nennenswerte Fortschritte. Das ist da so ein Straßenkampf und es ist auch
vollkommen unklar, wie genau so die Maps,
die man so sieht, sind, weil es ja jetzt auch nicht so, dass da jetzt die ganze
Zeit gemütlich irgendein Kartografierer durch die Straßen zieht.
Das ist alles so Stückwerk zusammengesetzt aus den ganzen Berichten,
die man hat und wo irgendjemand gesehen wurde.
Ob das jetzt heißt, wenn da ein russischer Trupp langläuft, ob das der einzige
ist oder ob da noch eine Hundertschaft hinterherzieht, ist immer alles schwer zu sagen.
Tatsache ist, auch dort hat sich eben nicht viel getan und das ist so dieses
Problem, in dem sich die Russen insgesamt befinden.
Ja, was so ein bisschen, ich meine es ist nicht ganz neu, aber es ist dazu genommen,
dass die Versorgungswege dann auch mit Netzen,
mit Antidrohennetzen komplett über viele Kilometer es quasi Tunnels gibt aus Netzen, die dann,
ich denke das sind Metallnetze so aus Stahl, Wobei dann wiederum die mit Thermit
angegriffen werden, um da Löcher dann wiederum rein zu schmelzen.
Also das ist schon eher krass. ja.
Ja, also Mad Max ist ein Scheiß dagegen, würde ich sagen.
Also es ist mittlerweile alles noch sehr viel dystopischer, als es glaube ich,
diese ganzen Filme mit dystopischer Zukunft das so bisher beschrieben haben.
Ja und mittlerweile auch auf beiden Seiten halt das Phänomen so Cope Cages und
Panzer, die dann ja eingepackt sind eben auch in Hühnerdraht und,
auch so versuchen, sich vor Drohnen zu schützen auf beiden Seiten jetzt.
Ja
Also was bleibt Russland noch? Sie haben halt immer noch ihre Propaganda am
Start und versuchen in irgendeiner Form auf so einer politischen Ebene,
in irgendeiner Form Fortschritte zu erzielen. Das können sie ja auch ganz gut.
Und Highlight der letzten Zeit war, dass sie gesagt haben, oh,
jetzt haben die Ukraine einen der Paläste von Putin angegriffen.
Alles ganz schlimm und haben es also wirklich gebracht, diesmal noch nicht mal
irgendwie so zu tun, als wäre da was passiert, sondern haben es halt einfach
mal nur irgendwie behauptet.
Trump, der Dussel, hat es natürlich dann auch gleich erstmal nachgeplappert,
wobei man bei ihm nie genau weiß, aus welchen Gründen er so etwas nachplappert.
Das kann auch alles Kalkül sein.
Ja, aber die letzte, also zuletzt nochmal nachgefragt, hat er dann gesagt,
er glaubt nicht, dass das stimme.
Ja, weil er irgendwie in der New York Post gelesen hat, dass Putin ihn an der
Nase herumführt. Das hat ihm natürlich auch nicht gefallen.
Ja, aber was halt faktisch man sagen kann, es gab in der Gegend kein Luftabwehrfeuer
in der Nähe des Palastes,
so ist es.
War dort in vielerlei Hinsicht Business as usual.
Der Flughafen, der da in der Nähe ist, hatte weiter Flugbetrieb.
Es gab keinen Alarm. All das sind so Fakten. man dann sagt, und keine Bilder.
Genau.
Ja, plus und keine Bilder, also mit anderen Worten, es war dort ruhig in der
Zeit, wo das angeblich passiert sein soll und das war also zu fern.
Es wurde dann auch nicht glaubhafter dadurch, dass sie danach noch so ein paar
AI generierte Bilder von dem angeblich beschädigten Palast erzeugt haben,
das ist auch relativ günstig zu finden, Aber es ist halt auch immer alles so, okay,
wir, also wir, nicht jetzt wir beide, aber sagen wir mal so die Leute,
die so diesen Krieg mit Argus Augen verfolgen und beobachten,
die lassen sich davon nicht täuschen.
Aber darum geht es ja auch. Es geht ja auch nicht um uns. Es geht um die Allgemeinheit,
es geht um so Flooding the Zone, Telegram-Kanäle,
Leute wollen ja dann auch mal das glauben, was ihnen gut in den Kram passt und
von daher mag das durchaus eine Technik sein, die funktioniert,
aber es hat jetzt, sagen wir mal,
auf internationaler Ebene zumindest wenig bis keinen Einfluss gehabt auf die,
ja, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das nennen soll, also Friedensgespräche ist,
glaube ich, ein vollkommen unangemessener Begriff, Aber sagen wir mal so diese
internationale Debatte, die so geführt wird in den Medien und auf der politischen
Ebene rund um Trump und das ist halt so eine Gemengelage,
die nicht allein entscheidend ist, aber zumindest damit einfließt,
wie sich denn das Heft des Handelns so verwandelt.
Also das war nicht so erfolgreich. Sehr viel erfolgreicher war allerdings wieder
eine coole Aktion vom ukrainischen Geheimdienst.
Es gibt da eine Person, Dennis Kapustin, ein Russe, ein Russe,
den man jetzt auch nicht unbedingt einladen will.
Also auch so ein rechtsgerichteter Hardcore-Russe, der aber mit Russland gebrochen hat.
Und der Anführer ist dieser Kampfeinheit, die eben nur aus Russen besteht und
die gegen Russland kämpft.
Also diese Vorstöße bei Kurs gab da so verschiedenste Vorstöße in den letzten zwei Jahren.
Das ist so die Person, die dem Ganzen vorsteht und es stellte sich dann raus,
dass die Russen einen Anschlag geplant hatten, um den zu killen.
Das machen sie ja ganz gerne.
So Leute, die so öffentlich sind und die sich so gegen den Staat stellen,
die müssen natürlich immer weg exekutiert werden.
Wir hatten das ja mit diesem Piloten, der ein Flugzeug von der Krim einfach
in der Ukraine gelandet hat und dann der Ukraine geschenkt hat und sich dann
nach Spanien verabschiedet hat.
Dann sind halt russische Geheimagenten hinter ihm her und haben ihn halt in Spanien ermordet.
Das ist so normal und da scheint auch eine ganze Menge Geld zu verdienen zu
sein, denn die Russen hatten wohl für die Ermordung von Kapustin 500.000 Euro.
US-Dollar.
US-Dollar, genau. Also eine halbe Million US-Dollar als Prämier ausgesetzt und
dementsprechend waren da auch ein paar unterwegs und wollten das machen.
Das hat aber der ukrainische Geheimdienst nicht nur herausgefunden und diese
Leute dann zumindest teilweise auch, glaube ich, dingfest gemacht.
Nein, sie haben das dann so gedreht, dass sie dann ein gefaktes Anschlagsvideo
produziert haben, wo dieser Kapustin vor so einem Bus steht,
also so einem kleinen Transporterfahrzeug irgendwo in der Ukraine,
irgendwo im Wald und dann gibt es so ein Drohnenvideo, wo halt so eine Kampfdrohne
auf den zufliegt und es sieht halt so aus, als würde er von dieser Drohne dann
wegexplodiert worden sein.
Kommt auch noch eine zweite Drohne hinterher, die dann nur noch irgendwie ein
brennendes Fahrzeug zeigt.
Man sieht jetzt nicht direkt sozusagen ihn und wie er dann explodiert ist,
aber offensichtlich hat das dann auch gereicht, weil das hat dann irgendwie dazu geführt,
dass sie einerseits dieses Video gelegt haben und zwar nicht an die Öffentlichkeit,
sondern erstmal nur an die Russen sozusagen.
Hier hat stattgefunden und sie dann aber auch noch flankierend über einen längeren
Zeitraum dann so öffentliche Meldungen verbreitet haben mit, ja hier,
Kapustin von den Russen umgebracht, total schade, irgendwie voll doof und haben
das dann erstmal eine Weile so im Raum stehen lassen.
Ja, aber war halt nicht so, sondern stattdessen hat der ukrainische Geheimdienst diese 500.000 Dollar,
eingesammelt und jetzt erst bekannt gegeben, dass das alles für die Katz war,
der Typ immer noch lebt, Da gab es so eine kleine Videokonferenz mit Budanov
und noch irgendeinem Vertreter und diesem Kapustien eben, wo sie sich dann einfach
so, ja, wir gratulieren Ihnen zur Wiederauferstehung.
Jetzt können Sie ja wieder an die Arbeit gehen, Dankeschön.
Das ist schon wirklich irre. Von Budanov hören wir gleich auch noch mal.
Denn Budanoff, also man muss ja sagen,
der Kirillo Budanoff, also wenn ihr von dem Typen, wenn ihr noch kein Bild von
ihm habt, ist glaube ich nach dem...
Ehemaligen Chef der Streitkräfte, der jetzt Botschafter in London ist, dem Salushny,
ist glaube ich der Budanov somit die populärste Person aus diesem Kriegspersonal
der Ukraine in der Ukraine.
Und das seitdem er den ukrainischen Geheimdienst geführt hat,
einfach für eine ganze Reihe von irren Aktionen immer wieder verantwortlich ist,
die ja sehr kreativ vorgehen, diese ganzen Spezialoperationen hier,
Operation Spiderweb und dieser Drohnenangriff auf die Flughäfen in Russland und was nicht alles.
Angriff auf die Kursbrücke, auf die Krimbrücke.
Also immer wieder diese ganzen Spezialaktionen, die obliegen sozusagen seiner Übersicht.
Und dazu ist er halt auch einfach noch so eine coole Sau, weil er einfach immer
seine Fassung behält, aber das auch mit so einem gewissen Humor auch präsentiert.
Also es ist einfach schon sehr speziell.
So, warum erwähne ich ihn jetzt? Weil er diese Position jetzt verlässt und stattdessen
wird er nämlich jetzt der Bürochef des Präsidenten und ihr erinnert euch,
wir hatten ja glaube ich in der letzten Sendung dann darüber berichtet,
über diesen Korruptionsfall, der schon seit ein paar Monaten die ukrainische
Bevölkerung aufgebracht hat, zu Recht.
Und unter anderem war ja eben der ehemalige Büroschef des Präsidenten,
dieser André Jermak, darin verwickelt und ist dementsprechend zurückgetreten.
Und jetzt stellte sich halt immer die Frage, okay, was macht Zelensky jetzt?
Und jetzt gab es eine größere Regierungsumbildung.
Und diese vakante Position im Bürochef des Präsidenten wird jetzt von Kirolo Budanov besetzt.
Denkt man sich so, eben noch Geheimdienstchef, jetzt irgendwie Bürochef klingt
ja jetzt ein bisschen wie eine Degradierung.
Nee, also der Jermak galt quasi als die klare Nummer zwei in der Ukraine.
Das ist derjenige, der für Zelensky an allen Verhandlungen teilgenommen hat,
diese ganzen Gespräche mit den USA und was nicht alles gemacht hat und generell
einen enormen Einfluss hatte in der Kritik stand.
Das hat ja dann letzten Endes auch zu seinem Niedergang mitgeführt.
Aber es war klar, dass einfach Zelensky an der Stelle jemanden haben will,
dem er vollständig vertraut und der halt irgendwie auch das Geschick mitbringt,
auch auf politischer Ebene sehr strategisch für die Ukraine zu kämpfen.
Und da ist jetzt seine Wahl eben auf diesen superpopulären Budanow gefallen.
Insofern glaube ich eine sehr kluge Wahl.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, hast du mal West Wing gesehen eigentlich?
Nee, nicht wirklich, was gab es da?
Naja, das ist halt so...
Amerika, wie es früher war.
Amerika, Weißes Haus, wie es früher war und da man halt schon ganz gut sehen,
so wie die Bedeutung, was die Bedeutung halt von so einem Stabschef eigentlich
ist, der dort gespielt hat,
oder dort Charakter ist irgendwie ein Leo McGarry und ja...
Da wird dann ganz gut deutlich, weil der sowohl entscheidet,
mit wem eigentlich der Präsident dann überhaupt spricht und der quasi macht halt eigentlich,
kontrolliert den Zugang zum Präsidenten und entscheidet selber,
was entschieden werden soll.
Und ist im Grunde genommen ein bisschen auch wie der erste Offizier auf einem
Schiff, der dann quasi der Mannschaft einfach sagt, was zu tun ist.
Der dann auch in alles involviert ist.
Und insofern, das kann man eben dort bei West Wing ganz gut sehen,
wie dort die Mechanik abläuft, was das bedeutet.
Bürochef oder eben Stabschef zu sein und wie viel Einfluss man als Stabschef eigentlich hat.
Ja, jetzt muss man natürlich sehen, wie es dem Geheimdienst da geht.
Jetzt ergeht, da wird dann ein Oleg Ivatschenko, der war vorher beim Auslandsgeheimdienst,
der Chef, der hat das jetzt irgendwie übernommen.
Aber es gab dann noch eine zweite Bewegung und zwar musste ja auch noch ein
Nachfolger gefunden werden für den geschassten Energieminister.
Und das wird Denis Schmierhal und das war der bisherige Verteidigungsminister.
Früher auch jahrelang Ministerpräsident in der Ukraine,
also ohnehin eine gestandene Figur in der ukrainischen Politik,
der jetzt halt ein halbes Jahr dieses Außenministerium geführt hat,
jetzt aber eben weiterzieht ins Energieministerium,
denn dort wird dann auch dann entsprechend eine neue Person eingesetzt,
das ist ja Michalo Fedorov und den finde ich ganz interessant insofern,
als dass er bisher formal Vizeministerpräsident war,
aber auch der Minister für die digitale Transformation der Ukraine und wohl
auch sehr tief in dieser ganzen ...
Diese Staatsmechanik des Umbaus, des Militärs ohnehin schon mit drin steckte,
was die ganze Drohnenproduktion, diese Startupisierung des militärischen Komplexes etc.
Genau weiß ich es jetzt im Detail auch nicht, aber er ist halt sehr jung,
34 Jahre alt und quasi sozusagen der digitale Transformer und man kann festhalten,
dass die Ukraine mit der digitalen Transformation auf jeden Fall deutlich besser
hinkriegt als Deutschland und von daher gehe ich mal davon aus,
dass die Besetzung mit ihm jetzt als Verteidigungsminister im Wesentlichen ein,
also er ist ja nicht derjenige, der den Krieg führt, sondern er ist sozusagen
der Apparat für den ganzen Kram.
Also hier geht es darum, eine Modernisierung der Armee weiter zu schreiben und
hier eben das auch alles mit dieser digitalen Kompetenz, die er mit sich bringt.
Ja, dann Kleinigkeiten, dass die Ukraine offenbar wieder ein paar Stormshadow
geliefert gekriegt hat,
mit denen sie dann sich Ziele auf russischem Boden auch angegriffen haben.
Und also Storm Shadow ist dieser englische Marschflugkörper,
der so zwischen je nach Variante zwischen 300 und 500 Kilometer weit fliegen
kann und offenbar technisch eben auch in der Lage ist,
tief zu fliegen und sich am Gelände anzupassen und halt ganz schwierig auch runterzuholen.
Sehr erfolgreich bisher in dem Krieg zum Einsatz gekommen, aber es war so ein
bisschen dünner mit der Versorgung.
Jetzt scheint es also wieder Material zu geben und vor allem wird es dann auch
gegen die Ölinfrastruktur zum Einsatz gebracht, nicht nur, aber auch.
Und dann hatten wir wieder, was wir seit langer Zeit nicht gehört hatten,
gab es wieder einen erfolgreichen Angriff auf mindestens ein Waffenarsenal in Russland.
Die heißen ja irgendwie Grau, G-R-A-U.
So sind so große Waffenlager und da hatte die Ukraine ja eine ganze Reihe von
in die Luft gejagt eine Zeit lang und das war sehr einfach,
weil die Russen sich nicht die Mühe gemacht hatten, die Munition in die Bunker
zu packen, sondern die einfach dann auf dem Bahnsteig oder am Straßenrand mehr
oder weniger einfach ausgepackt haben,
weil morgen muss das ja sowieso raus,
da braucht man das jetzt nicht irgendwie in den Bunker zu packen,
wenn nächste Woche das abtransportiert wird.
Und das war ziemlich übel und dann haben sie aber daraufhin dann angefangen,
tatsächlich ihre Munition in die Bunker zu packen, was es dann eben deutlich aufwendiger macht,
weil du dann Waffen brauchst, die auch in der Lage sind,
dann durch den Beton durchzugehen oder durch das Tor, also im Prinzip bunkerbrechende Waffen oder ...
Oder teilweise können das halt die modernen Marschflugkörper auch,
die haben dann teilweise mehrere Sprengladungen, so eine Hohlladung,
die dann einen Kanal frei macht, sodass das Geschoss dann einfach tief penetrieren kann.
Und da scheint es der Ukraine auch gelungen zu sein,
jetzt wieder ein größeres Waffenlager dort erfolgreich anzugreifen,
sodass es massive Sekundärexplosionen gab.
Und ja, das fand ich auch nochmal bemerkenswert.
Das war bemerkenswert, vor allem, also es ist halt auch so eins der Waffenlager,
die nicht so viele Bunker hatten, sondern wo im Wesentlichen nur so Hütten sind,
also von daher ganz dankbar, aber gegebenenfalls schwierig zu erreichen,
weil dann eben wieder ziemlich weit weg, also ungefähr so 1000 Kilometer entfernt von Rakiv.
Und das zeigt einfach, dass sie mit diesen Systemen, mit denen sie das angreifen,
ist jetzt nicht klar, womit sie das gemacht haben,
dass sie eben auch diese Distanzen machen können, weil das war definitiv kein
Storm Shadow, sondern ihre eigenen
Long-Range-Drohnen, von denen sie ja mittlerweile eine ganze Menge haben.
Aber sie schreiben jetzt natürlich auch immer nicht dazu, was gerade zum Einsatz kam.
Ja, ich würde sagen, das ist so im Wesentlichen das, was sich jetzt in den letzten
zwei Wochen nochmal so abgezeichnet hat.
Jetzt wollten wir aber mal auf diese Venezuela-Situation zu sprechen kommen
und zwar weil das eben nicht wirklich entkoppelt gesehen oder nicht vollständig
entkoppelt ist von dem Geschehen.
Ich meine, wir haben es mittlerweile mit so einer Großmacht,
Großwetterlage zu tun, möchte ich mal sagen.
Es gibt halt viel Gerede über die Aufteilung der Welt und Trump schnappt sich
jetzt die Amerikas und Europa ist ihm egal und dann lass doch die Russen machen, was sie wollen.
Nach dem Motto, sodass wir in Taiwan jetzt glaube ich auch in zunehmendem Maße
ein bisschen Schiss kriegen, weil das nicht unbedingt jetzt nach einer bedingungslosen
Verteidigung Taiwans klingt,
auch wenn das sehr wohl im Interesse der USA wäre, das zu tun.
Das könnte das Ende des amerikanischen Einflusses in Asien sein und am Ende glaube ich wird auch,
wenn sie dann auch in Australien und Neuseeland sich nochmal Gedanken darüber
machen wie denn das jetzt eigentlich mit der USA so ist aber wir wissen ja,
es interessiert Trump nicht, es geht nur darum,
genug Kohle für seine Cronies und sich selbst vor allem seine Familie zu machen Ja.
Also Also es ist insofern relevant für den Ukraine-Krieg, was dort passiert ist,
weil das Ganze schon auch massiven Einfluss hat auf die Stimmung in der Bevölkerung
und in den russischen Eliten.
Und das, was sie dort jetzt gesehen
haben, fanden sie halt unglaublich frustrierend und demoralisierend.
Also im Grunde genommen zwei Dinge. Das erste Ding war, dass sie gesehen haben,
Dass die Amerikaner in der Lage sind, einen Staatschef rauszuholen,
ohne auch nur einen einzigen Hubschrauber oder Soldaten zu verlieren aus einem fremden Land.
Und nicht nur irgendein Land, sondern eins, wo Putin noch vor ein paar Wochen
große Worte gemacht hat.
Von wegen ja und wir unterstützen einen Verbündeter Russlands,
dem sie dann auch noch versucht hatten, mehr Flugabwehrsysteme zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Und der von einer kubanischen Palastwache bewacht wurde.
Und ja, also all das und dann so patsch-patsch,
so greifen die sich einfach den Maduro in einer doch sehr spektakulären Aktion,
wo sich dann natürlich jeder fragte,
sind die Amerikaner so gut und die Venezuelaner so schlecht oder hatte da irgendjemand
einen Deal mit dem venezuelanischen Militär gemacht?
Haltet mal die Füße still, sonst wird es noch schlimmer.
Es ist wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen eine Kombination aus beiden.
Einerseits waren die Amerikaner halt hervorragend informiert,
also haben das Land vorher komplett ausgekundschaftet und hatten bestimmt auch
Leute überall im Apparat.
Die denen Informationen gegeben haben, sodass sie in der Lage waren,
dann auch die Flugabwehr lahmzulegen, komplett.
Und dann schien auch die Motivation des venezuelanischen Militärs,
das Land zu verteidigen, jetzt nicht so spontan, nicht so groß gewesen zu sein.
Obwohl es wohl, also wie viel Gegenwehr es gegeben hat, ist so ein bisschen unklar.
Es gab ein bisschen Gegenwehr und es sollen irgendwie auf venezuelanischer Seite
so 60, um die 60 Tote gegeben haben bei den Angriffen darauf eine ganze Menge.
Bestand wohl aus dieser kubanischen Palastwache, die Maduro da beschützen sollte.
Aber ja, das war auf jeden Fall erstmal die erste Klatsche, dass ein Land,
was eigentlich unter dem Schutz Russlands steht, Amerika komplett hilflos ausgeliefert ist.
In anderen Worten, die Hilfe oder Unterstützung durch Russland oder durch Putin
ist halt nichts wert oder ist sogar eher umgekehrt.
Natürlich die Meme halt jetzt wie viele Diktatoren in den letzten Jahren,
wo Putin gesagt hat, so wie Merkel damals,
wenn sie es mit dem unbegrenztes Vertrauen oder so ausspricht.
Hat mein vollstes Vertrauen.
Genau, vollstes Vertrauen.
Der Diktator hat unser vollstes Vertrauen.
Ja, ja. Und bei Putin ist es, also Venezuela hat unsere volle Unterstützung
in ihrem antiimperialistischen Kampf und ja.
Hat halt nichts genutzt. Das war die erste Klatsche.
Und die letzte Klatsche jetzt war die Sache mit dem Tanker.
Wobei, das war jetzt vielleicht der dritte oder vierte Öltanker.
Ich glaube, das war der vierte jetzt.
Vielleicht sollten wir erstmal ein
bisschen die Timeline konkret dieses venezolanischen Kontextes aufmachen.
Jetzt vorweg halt, also wie du schon richtig sagtest, die Russen betrifft das.
Sie haben Assad verloren, damit haben sie irgendwie den Zugang verloren zu dem
Mittelmeer und natürlich auch extrem an Einfluss in der ganzen Nahostregion verloren.
Aber in Iran, kommen wir vielleicht nachher noch zu, sieht es auch gerade nicht so gut aus.
Auch das haben ja die Amerikaner mal zusammen mit den Israelis mal 0,0x zusammengebombt,
sodass zwar jetzt nicht das Regime gestürzt ist, aber zumindest die militärische
Bedrohung, die jetzt vom Iran ausgeht,
signifikant abgeschwächt wurde.
Auch dort war quasi die Präsenz der Russen und der russischen Abwehrtechnik quasi breit.
Egal, weil sie können halt derzeit einfach nirgendswo was tun.
Und würden die Russen jetzt in irgendeiner Form an einer anderen Front angegriffen
werden, außer jetzt da in der Ukraine, könnten sie dem wahrscheinlich auch herzlich
wenig entgegensetzen. Ja, das muss man auch mal so abwarten.
China, Georgien, das sind alles so Fragezeichen im Raum. Darum soll es jetzt
aber erstmal nicht gehen.
Aber deswegen ist das eben auch relevant.
Aber schauen wir mal, was eigentlich passiert ist. Das fing ja vor ein paar
Wochen an, muss zugeben, ich habe es am Anfang auch alles nicht so intensiv
verfolgen wollen, weil mir das so viel Kleinkram erschien. Ich glaube, so ging es auch vielen.
Erst mal hat halt die Trump-Regierung da so eine Chimäre aufgesetzt mit,
ja, hier wir tun jetzt mal was gegen Drogenhandel und so und dann haben sie halt irgendwelche.
Boote in der Karibik weggebombt, die Leute da gekillt, wo vollkommen unklar
war, ob das jetzt einfach nur irgendwelche Fischer waren oder doch vielleicht
irgendwelche Kuriere, aber das war halt erst mal nur so ein bisschen den Zeh ins Wasser halten.
Dann fingen sie langsam an, mehr und mehr,
Ihre Armada dort zusammenzuziehen, unter anderem ihren größten Flugzeugträger,
aber auch noch viele andere Schiffe, Flugzeuge, alles mögliche.
Also sie hatten halt einfach schon mal eine signifikante militärische Präsenz
und sie haben halt auch in zunehmendem Maße da so eine Seeblockade aufgezogen
und Schiffe kontrolliert.
Ja, also ich würde mal sagen, so 20 Prozent der Navy haben sie ungefähr hingeschickt.
So viel?
Ja, ja. Also es waren deutlich über 100 Schiffe,
die sie hingeschickt haben und die Navy hat 550 im Moment sowas,
wobei halt man damit rechnen kann, dass die Hälfte immer irgendwo im Trockendock sich befindet.
Und insofern ist das ja, ich sage größenordnungsmäßig,
durchsagen sind es so 15 Prozent,
aber von den Einsatzbereiten sind es eher fast 30 Prozent, wobei je nachdem,
ob man das jetzt in Stückzahl Schiffe oder in Bruttoregistertonnen rechnet,
gibt sich da nochmal andere.
Das dürfte schon mehr sein, als irgendein anderes Land überhaupt aufzubringen.
In der Lage ist, mit der einzigen Ausnahme von China.
Ja, also die mittlerweile sehr.
Sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr große Nevi.
Plus, was dazu kommt, dass sie ja auch noch eine Reihe von Militärstützpunkten
in der Gegend haben, von denen sie dann auch aus Einsätze geflogen sind.
Also unglaubliche Militärpräsenz, dann die angefangen ja jetzt Kriegsverbrechen zu begehen,
dann dort beziehungsweise der erste Strike stellte sich heraus,
war ja dann ziemlich eindeutig ein Kriegsverbrechen mit dem Double Tap,
wo sie halt dann auf zwei Leute,
die im Wassertrieben geschossen haben,
was ganz klar ein Kriegsverbrechen ist und sogar mehr als Beispiel genau genannt
ist im amerikanischen Militärhandbuch so für, was ist ein Kriegsverbrechen?
Genau das.
Genau das. Daraufhin haben sie wohl dann selber ein bisschen,
irgendwelche Leute müssen dann Muffensausen gekriegt haben, weil als das nächste
Mal Leute überlebt hatten, haben sie die einfach wieder an Land gesetzt und
noch nicht mal verhaftet.
Als das dann wieder passiert ist bei irgendeinem Strike, es Überlebende gab, wurden die einfach ja,
Wieder an Land zurückgebracht, was dann halt auch ganz klar macht,
dass es nicht um Drogen geht oder dass sie gar keine Beweise hatten,
weil sonst hätten sie die ja auch verhaften oder den Prozess machen können.
Aber da gab es offensichtlich null Strafverfolgungsinteresse,
weil das vermutlich noch nicht mal.
Sie geben sich noch nicht mal Mühe, ihre Storys auch nur irgendwie halbwegs
sinnvoll und plausibel erscheinen zu lassen.
Ja, so damit, genau, das lief dann erst mal und dann mit verschiedenen Drohungen,
die dann von Trump unter anderem abgegeben wurden, so nach dem Motto, okay,
wenn du das Land nicht verlässt, so.
Am Anfang war es so, ja wir wollen jetzt hier mal die Drogenhändler festnehmen
und dann wurde diese Erzählung halt so weiter gesponnen mit,
ja ihr seid ja generell als Staat hier sozusagen ein Problem,
was ein bisschen absurd ist auf der einen Seite, weil sie halt die ganze Zeit
immer von dieser Fentanyl-Geschichte reden, womit jetzt eigentlich Venezuela nichts zu tun hat.
Sehr wohl sind sie natürlich Teil des gesamten Drogenhandels in dieser Region.
Das ist auch vollkommen unbestritten.
Aber es ging halt jetzt eigentlich darum, so eine Geschichte aufzubauen,
mit dass Maduro jetzt das Problem sei.
Und es wurde dann wohl hinter den Kulissen ihm auch schon mehrfach bedeutet,
er solle dann mal gehen, so hier, geht auch irgendwie würfeln mit Assad.
Die Russen würden dich wahrscheinlich schon nehmen. Und er so,
nö, ich habe hier meine Kubaner, mir kann gar nichts passieren. kommt doch. Ja, und dann,
haben sie das auch gemacht.
Ja, ich meine, womit...
Trump tatsächlich recht hat, ist,
dass Maduro und seine Frau, die kann man ja auch, genau, Celia Flores sagen, die Frau von Maduro.
Es ist interessant, dass oft diese autoritären Herrscher dann meistens Frauen haben,
die Rechtsanwälte sind und nicht ihren Namen nicht den Namen des Mannes angenommen haben.
Ist ja in Ungarn genau dasselbe.
Hatten wir auch mal das Thema so und ja und Maduro und seine Frau sind tatsächlich.
Beide hochgradig kriminell. Also sie sind auch direkt in den Drogenhandel verwickelt,
also dazu muss man wissen.
Ein bisschen wie das mit dem Drogenhandel dort funktioniert.
Also speziell jetzt erstmal was den Kokainhandel angeht, weil das ist das,
wo jetzt Maduro und Celia Flores so verwickelt sind.
Und zwar vom Kokain, ich glaube 70, 80 Prozent weltweit der Kokainproduktion ist in Kolumbien.
So, da kommt das Kokain her.
Jetzt sind aber diese Drogenkartelle mittlerweile nicht mehr,
wie es so schön heißt, vertikal integriert.
Das heißt von der Produktion bis zum Vertrieb, sondern die meisten Drogenkartelle
sind in erster Linie jetzt im Vertriebsgeschäft.
Das heißt, die kaufen einfach das Kokain in Kolumbien auf dem freien Markt,
auf dem freien Kokainmarkt.
Und arrangieren dann das Verschiffen und die Distribution und so.
Und ein Zentrum, also einiges davon passiert in Mexiko, so mexikanische Kartelle.
Aber ein Großteil, also wichtiger Punkt oder Ort geschäftlicher Aktivität ist eben auch Venezuela,
weil das grenzt halt an Kolumbien und in diesem Grenzgebiet dann im Westen von Venezuela,
so gab es halt eine hohe Konzentration von Kartellen, die von da aus das Geschäft organisiert haben.
Und die wurden aber dann in den letzten Jahren, ich weiß gar nicht genau wann
das war, aber wurden dann vom venezuelanischen Militär vertrieben,
weil man selber das Geschäft in die Hand nimmt.
Also im Grunde genommen ist das venezuelanische Militär im selben Geschäft auch
wie die Drogenkartelle,
das heißt organisiert eben dann ja den Vertrieb und den Versand und Handel.
Und dafür gibt es halt, das ist jetzt keine Verschwörungstheorie,
sondern das ist allgemein bekannt, dass dem so ist und auch seine Maduros Frau, Frau Flores,
zwei von ihren Neffen wurden in den USA wegen Drogenhandels verhaftet, weil eben genau,
also ihre ganze Familie ist da im Prinzip verwickelt und ja,
die wurden halt zu jeweils 18 Jahren Haft verurteilt, aber im Oktober 2022 wurden
sie dann freigelassen im Austausch für sieben in Venezuela inhaftierte US-Amerikaner.
Also es gab dann quasi einen Gefangenenaustausch, auch so Drogenhändler,
Verwandte von Maduros Frau gegen inhaftierte Amerikaner, so.
Und das ist also ja alles bekannt und interessant ist aber auch, dass halt,
oder wissen muss ist, dass ein Großteil der Ware dann gar nicht venezuelanischen
Boden erreicht oder nicht von Venezuela aus exportiert wird, Sondern die Routen,
die Transportrouten gehen dann halt oft direkt von Kolumbien aus.
Die sorgen nur dafür, dass das Schiff zur richtigen Zeit da anlandet,
dass die richtigen Leute bestochen werden und die richtigen Papiere gefälscht werden und ja,
also so läuft das.
Das ist im Prinzip wie der Aktienmarkt und Handelsmarkt für Nahrungsmitteltransporte.
Und da sind natürlich auch die mexikanischen Kartelle auch tief mit drin,
aber wie du schon sagtest, es ist halt jetzt nicht mehr so ein Land allein und
da wird es dann auch transportiert, sondern es ist so ein internationaler Handelsmarkt,
der halt so komplett parallel zum Legalen läuft.
Ja und venezuelische Militär liefert auch mehr Kokain nach Europa als in die USA.
Die haben halt mehr so den Europa-Fokus. Ein bisschen Asien,
aber nicht so sehr. Und in den USA ist der Markt nämlich komplett übersättigt im Moment mit Kokain.
Also die Kokainpreise fallen so. Das sind eine der wenigen Verbraucherpreise.
Sag ich mal, wo man sagen kann, ja, da hat...
Donald Trump dafür gesorgt, dass irgendwie die Preise zurückgehen,
was halt auch irgendwie irre ist,
weil man ja denken würde, so mit dem neuen Grenzregime und so,
aber das scheint nichts wirklich großartig zu tun, was jetzt Drogen angeht,
zumal ich habe immer versucht auch rauszufinden,
auf welche Art und Weise denn jetzt die Drogen in die USA kommen Und es ist halt schwierig,
dort belastbare Zahlen zu finden.
Das Einzige ist, wo wie viel beschlagnahmt wird.
Und 80 oder 90 Prozent der Drogen, die in den USA beschlagnahmt werden beim
Schmuggeln, kommen auf dem Landweg.
Wie bei Mexiko, weil du hast halt so intensive Handlungsbeziehungen,
dass wahrscheinlich jeden Tag zigtausend LKW einfach über die Grenze rollen,
die irgendwelche Autoteile oder weiß der Geier was liefern.
Und das ist einfach so viel, dass eine lückenlose Kontrolle da einfach nicht möglich ist.
Und angeblich per Schiff kommen nur 5 bis 10 Prozent oder der beschlagnahmenden
Mengen, die per Schiff reinkommen, liegen nur bei 5 bis 10 Prozent,
wobei das entweder daran liegen kann, dass da nicht so viel kommt oder dass
es noch schwieriger ist,
weil da kommt ein Containerschiff dann mit 2000 Containern an und in drei von
den 2000 Containern ist irgendwo,
Da sind halt die Drogen drin und es ist unmöglich, dann jeden Container wirklich
zu untersuchen und wenn das gut verpackt ist und so, dann machst du da einfach nichts offenbar.
Das, ja, das Mexiko ist tatsächlich mehr so Fentanyl und gibt da auch,
also Chinesen sind da auch mit drin,
so von wegen die Chemikalien, die jetzt für die Synthese von Fentanyl benötigt
werden, kommen größtenteils aus China wiederum und das ist nochmal ein ganz anderes Ding.
Aber wir sind jetzt bei Venezuela und kann feststellen, ich war in den 90ern
mal da für zwei Wochen und habe das Land bereist.
Ja, das war damals schon, das war noch vor Chavez, war das schon das korrupteste Jahr.
In dem ich je gewesen bin. Die einzigen Leute, die gut gelaunt waren,
waren Polizisten und Militärs.
Die waren alle sehr entspannt, offenbar.
Und du konntest die dann auch einfach für Geld, konntest du da alles anheuern.
Also erst mal damit an.
Irre Kriminalitätsrate, das ist bis heute noch.
Also Caracas hat mit die höchste Mordrate auch. Also die Kriminalität war einfach krass.
Ampeln sind reine Empfehlungen, da hält sich niemand dran. Es gibt keine Alkoholkontrollen,
keine Drogenkontrollen.
Das heißt, grob der Fahrer fährt halt betrunken und auf Kokain.
Auch die Busfahrer, also Überlandbusse, werden halt mithilfe von Koks gestört.
Ich habe dann versucht, mal hinter so einem Bus hinten dran zu bleiben ohne Kokain.
So war einfach unmöglich, weil der Bretterte dann mit 140 durch die Dörfer während
am Straßenrand ohne Gehwege so zwei- bis dreijährige Kinder spielen und der
Bretterte mit dem Bus da durch.
Und da werden öfter dann auch mal Kinder überfahren oder überfahren und wenn
das passiert, dann flüchtet der Busfahrer in der Regel ein paar Kilometer weiter,
stellt den Bus ab und rennt in den Dschungel.
So, weil er ansonsten nämlich gelüncht wird von den Leuten aus dem Dorf, wenn da was passiert.
So läuft das da ab. Ansonsten.
Sie sehen weite Teile des Landes aus wie in so einem Horrorfilm.
Sie ist halt früher mal richtig teure, also wohlhabende Struktur,
nur ist alles überwuchert und runtergekommen.
Und die Leute, die da rumlaufen, sehen auch alle aus wie irgendwelche Kriminellen aus einem Thriller.
Man wird versucht, überall versuchen sie dich zu bescheißen oder auszurauben.
Oder wenn du in einem Hotel auf dem Land oder kleineren Städten bist,
musst du dein Auto, darfst du nicht auf der Straße parken, wenn es ein Mietwagen ist.
Sondern er gehört zu jedem Hotel, dann gehört ein Parkplatz,
der ist so mit 8 bis 10 Meter hohen,
Betonpanelen mit drei Reihen NATO-Draht oben drüber das ist wie das Auto abgesichert
ist und ins Hotel kommst du nur über eine Schleuse, wie auch im Gefängnis,
so mit Gittertüren machst du erst die eine Gittertür auf oder die,
dann gehst du da rein und dann die Gittertür zu und dann so vergitterter Schalter, wo du dann,
dich ausweisen musst und wer du bist und beweisen, dass du da jetzt auch irgendwie
ein Zimmer hast oder so und erst dann geht die zweite Tür auf.
Vor jeder Tankstelle stand damals so Typen mit Lederjacken und einer Schrotflinte doppelläufigen,
so direkt in der Einfahrt, als Abschreckung einfach und das obwohl der Liter
Benzin zwei Cent gekostet hat,
ist mittlerweile deutlich teurer geworden, kostet jetzt drei Cent der Liter so nach 20 Ja.
Gott.
Es gab nämlich mal Unruhen, als der erhöht wurde von zwei Cent auf,
ich weiß nicht, haben sie noch vier Cent und daraufhin gab es dann eine Revolution,
weil die Spritpreise zu hoch waren.
Das heißt, dann unseren Jeep, den wir da hatten, oder das war ein Range Rover,
glaube ich, waren wir unterwegs.
Einmal volltanken, 50 Cent.
Für ein, zwei Dollar kannst du halt dann deinen Tank voll machen.
Und wie gesagt, es ist immer noch so, also drei Cent pro Liter ist der Spritpreis.
Was natürlich auch ein Problem ist,
dann...
Wird im Wesentlichen verschenkt. Dann Strom, dasselbe, es gibt ein paar ziemlich
große Wasserkraftwerke dort, von denen ich eins besichtigt habe,
auch das ist ja irgendwie das größte Binnensee,
da habe ich glaube einer der größten Stauseen in der Gegend oder weltweit.
Und der Strom wird dann, siehst du dann auch, über riesige Hochspannungsstromtrassen
mitten durch den Dschungel geleitet, bis hin dann in die Slums.
Und die Slums sind dann so Berge, die aussehen wie Christbäume.
Also jedenfalls was die Beleuchtung angeht. Du hast dann halt so einen Berg
und der sieht aus wie ein Berg mit weißer Christbaumbeleuchtung,
weil dort quasi die Straßenbeleuchtung, also alle Beleuchtung besteht aus nackten
Glühbirnen, die in Fassungen sitzen.
Und es zahlt eigentlich auch kaum jemand für strom in dem land so also definitiv
die slums haben keine uhren sondern die haben,
Traditionell Strom geklaut, aber seit Chavez brauchen sie nicht mal das mehr
zu tun, sondern da gibt es halt dann freie Stromkontingente für die Armen.
Also das Land und das, obwohl das Land gehörte mal zu den reichsten Ländern
oder war sogar nach Bruttoinlandsprodukt, also pro Kopf,
das zeitlang das reichste Land der Welt wegen dem Ölreichtum.
Und hat dann aber auch wie kaum ein anderes Land unter dem Fluch des Öls gelitten.
Und zwar, was halt passiert, wenn du in einem Land viel Öl hast,
ist, dass das so viel Profit liefert,
dass sich andere wirtschaftliche Aktivitäten praktisch nicht lohnen.
Also wenn du jetzt Kapital zu investieren hast, dann lohnt es sich,
dann hast du, wenn du das jetzt, weiß ich nicht, in ein IT-Startup oder in irgendein,
keine Ahnung, Bäckerei oder was auch immer,
normale Industrie investierst, hast du vielleicht ein Zehntel der Rendite.
Das heißt, da wurde dann halt auch keine substanzielle Wirtschaft aufgebaut.
Deswegen hat Norwegen zum Beispiel, weil davon gewusst haben,
diesen Fonds geschaffen, damit das bloß nicht in den Staatshaushalt direkt fließt, das Geld.
Weil das, wenn du billiges Öl auf deinem Land hast, ruiniert das einfach den
Rest deiner Wirtschaft.
Und dann kam dazu.
Das, weil es dann aber, ja,
weil man das Volk dann auch ruhigstellen wollte, hat man dann auch trotz dieses
Öls über seine Verhältnisse gewirtschaftet und erstmal hat Venezuela,
ja, hat ohne Ende Kredite aufgenommen.
Kurze Anmerkung, also du redest von der holländischen Krankheit, ne?
Ach, nennt sich das auch holländische Krankheit?
Ja genau, weil es auch in den Niederlanden in den 60er Jahren mit den Erdgasvorkommen
so war, dass du genau diesen selben Effekt hattest.
Und Norwegen scheint ja tatsächlich das einzige Land zu sein,
was das irgendwie in den Griff bekommen hat, indem sie einfach gesagt hat,
wir verstaatlichen das, wir zahlen da in den Fonds für alle ein.
Und geben das jetzt nicht aus, sondern das wird investiert in etwas anderes
und nicht irgendwie dazu genommen, um den Staatshaushalt jetzt zu füllen.
Ja und dann natürlich mit den ganzen Öl, also größten Ölvorkommen der Welt,
hat natürlich jeder gerne Kredite gegeben.
Aber irgendwann kam es dann eben auch zu Ölkrise und,
irgendwann brach dann auch der Ölpreis ist halt stark zyklisch und irgendwann
ging der Ölpreis in den Keller und das ganze System flog ihnen um die Ohren.
Es gab dann massive Pleiten.
Du siehst dann auch noch, dass ich.
Wie so Lost Places am Meer, so eine Bungalow- oder Ferienhaus-Siedlung,
die dann aber entweder nie fertig wurde oder seit 20 Jahren dann verlassen ist.
Also jede Menge Ruinen überall oder alte Hotels,
die super pompös mit Parks und Statuen und nur alles so zugewuchert und definitiv runtergekommen.
Und damals, als ich da war, das war so Mitte der 90er, wie gesagt,
vor Chavez war die Situation richtig krank.
Beschissen für die Bevölkerung. So 60% oder 70% irgendwie in der Gegend waren
arbeitslos, also hatten kein Einkommen,
und um zu überleben, mussten dann von den 30%, die was haben,
mit allen Mitteln versuchen, von denen zu stehlen, zu rauben.
Zu erprostituieren, was auch
immer mit allen Mitteln, versuchen dann genug zum Überleben zu kriegen.
Das ist ja weshalb die Kriminalitätsrate auch so groß war.
Also es hieß dann, wenn wir in Caracas ausgehen wollen, dann nur in Gruppen
mindestens zehn Leute nur so viel Geld mitnehmen, wie man für den Abend braucht.
Und bei Anzeichen von Überfall einfach das Geld rausrücken, weil man sonst Gefahr
läuft, einfach erschossen zu werden.
Das heißt, du planst dann schon erstmal in einer Gruppe von zehn,
es ist unwahrscheinlicher, dass man überfallen wird, aber zu zweit oder dritt
ist es zu gefährlich, sich in der Innenstadt zu bewegen oder auszugehen.
Und selbst dann mit zehn Leuten musst du damit rechnen, trotzdem überfallen
zu werden und deswegen deine Papiere zu Hause lassen und quasi ein Go-Kit für
Überfall. So, okay, hier.
Ja, das war Venezuela vor Chavez in den 90ern.
Und ja, insofern...
Ich meine, Chavez hatte auch versucht, sich 1992 schon mal per Militärputsch
an die Macht zu bringen. Das hat nicht funktioniert.
Aber 1998 wurde er dann tatsächlich gewählt bei demokratischen Wahlen.
Und wenn man sich dann überlegt, in welchem katastrophalen Zustand das Land war,
wie groß die Unterschiede zwischen arm und reich und das Elend,
war es dann kein Wunder, dass dann Chavez auch erstmal so beliebt war.
Weil er hat dann tatsächlich eine ganze Menge guter Dinge getan für die Bevölkerung.
Also Ärzte aus Kuba geholt und auch dann den armen Gesundheitsdienst,
hat Sozialwohnungen gebaut und sagt dann auch noch,
nicht nur Sprit, sondern eben auch Strom und Wasser subventioniert oder verschenkt.
Und tatsächlich ist dann in den ersten Jahren so Armut, Ungleichheit,
Kindersterblichkeit zurückgegangen und auch Schulen und so, also der Analphabetismus ist zurückgegangen.
Also die ersten Jahre so war Chavez super beliebt,
nachdem er gewählt wurde und hat dann mit je nachdem zwischen 60 und 80 Prozent
tatsächlich der Stimmen bekommen,
einfach weil die Situation vorher so desaströs war, wie gesagt,
wie ich das beschrieben hatte, es ist.
Ja, und das lief alles soweit gut, sogar auch das Bruttoinlandsprodukt hatte
sich in der Zeit von Chavez, was ich gesehen habe,
so verdrei- oder vervierfacht.
Also die Zahlen gingen auch erstmal nach oben und das war halt super beliebt.
Aber es hatte auch was mit dem Ölpreis zu tun, weil Chavez dann Glück hatte,
dass als er dann die Regierung übernommen hat,
der Ölpreis in die Höhe gegangen ist und damit plötzlich auch wieder Geld da
war, eine ganze Menge zu finanzieren.
Nur als Chavez dann gestorben ist an Krebs, 2013 war das, hat dann Maduro übernommen.
Und Maduro war erstens nicht so fähig, aber tatsächlich ging dann auch der Ölpreis zurück.
Also das heißt auch der ganze Handlungsspielraum wurde problematisch.
Und was eben auch Chavez gemacht hat und die ganze Partei.
Korruption ist dort ganz normal und Nepotismus auch,
das heißt die haben dann auch die Ölgesellschaft so sämtliche Spitzenposten allein 30.
Mitarbeiter bei dieser staatlichen Ölgesellschaft sind verwandt mit der Frau
von Maduro also sind irgendwie,
so
Ein Zufall aber.
Auch Ja, und sind auch in den Posten gekommen, nachdem Maduro dann getreten ist.
Und das hat dann wiederum dazu geführt, plus auch externe Faktoren wie Sanktionen.
Also mal wurden dann mehr Sanktionen verhängt, mal wurden dann wieder zurückgefahren.
Achso, und sie haben dann natürlich die Ölindustrie komplett verstaatlicht.
Weswegen Trump jetzt auch, wir sagen für die amerikanischen Firmen,
die wollen ihre Ölfirmenanteile wieder zurück,
die im Rahmen der Verstaatlichung dann ihnen weggenommen wurden.
Das ist so auch, war so ein Problem.
Ein Ding. Ja, also Venezuela ist einfach krasses Land.
So ist ein Wunder, dass es halt überhaupt irgendwas funktioniert,
aber es funktioniert auch nicht viel.
So muss man sagen. Aber es gibt Strom wegen der großen Staudämme.
Es gibt billigen Sprit wegen der Ölvorkommen. Und ja, Wasser gibt es dort eigentlich
auch genug, aber das muss man natürlich noch aufbereiten.
Ja, aber jedenfalls, ja, wirtschaftlich ging es eben seit Chavez-Tod wiederum nur bergab.
Und aktuell ist das Bruttoinlandsprodukt, also die letzten Zahlen,
die ich hatte, war wieder so weit unten wie vor dem Chavez-Boom.
Also sagen Maduro hat alles geschafft zu verzocken oder es ist so weit zurückgegangen
wieder und deswegen war dann auch die Bevölkerung jetzt nicht mehr so begeistert,
sondern hat dann in den letzten Wahlen dann eben gegen die Partei von Chavez und Maduro,
also die PSUV oder die Vereinigte Sozialistische Partei Venezuelas,
Das wurde dann effektiv abgewählt,
aber als linksautoritäres Regime haben sie dann einfach das Wahlergebnis ignoriert
und sind dann an der Macht geblieben.
Weil einerseits ist das Militär, aus dem Chavez ursprünglich kam, Maduro nicht.
Und.
Ja, sie haben außerdem noch sowas wie,
Amerika gibt es die Nationalgarde unter
Hitler gab es dann unter anderem
auch eben Volkswarte und jedenfalls sie haben auch noch Bewaffnete auf lokalem
Level Also im Grunde genommen jeder in jedem Block oder kleinen Städtchen gibt
es dann eben auch nochmal eine Volkswehr,
wenn du so willst, die bewaffnet ist und eben auch der Partei unterstellt ist,
um dann dort für Ruhe und Ordnung zu sorgen.
So, das ist auch nochmal ein wichtiger Punkt.
Und wie gesagt, dann gibt es noch die Polizei und alle sind mega korrupt.
Also als ich da war, wollte ich auf diesem Stausee einen Bootstrip machen,
aber es ist halt komplett verboten, irgendwie auf diesem See halt irgendwie
rumzufahren, weil Sicherheitszone und überhaupt, um zu dem Staudamm zu kommen,
sich durch drei Polizeikontrollen, die weiteste war 40 Kilometer von dem Staudamm entfernt.
Und die ganze Gegend ist da um den Staudamm und unter dem Staudamm befindet
sich auch ein Dorf, das sieht aus wie so ein 50er Jahre Amerika Suburb mit,
Bungalows und gemähtem Rasen und Bürgersteige das waren die einzigen Bürgersteige,
die ich in dem ganzen Land gesehen hatte und das ist wie aus so einem Science Fiction Was heißt.
Unter dem Stausee? also jetzt geflutet oder davor?
Nein, nein, nein, davor, davor. Sagen für den Betrieb von dem Stausee.
Haben die halt irgendwie so ein amerikanisches Suburb dahin gepflanzt,
wahrscheinlich für die ausländischen Experten, die den Damm betrieben und gebaut
oder dann betrieben haben.
Ja, und ich wollte dann halt, weil ich meine, ein großer Stausee Bootstour wäre echt super.
Und dann habe ich einfach gefragt,
dann, wo man denn hier vielleicht ein Boot mieten kann oder so und wurde natürlich
an den Polizeichef verwiesen,
der da natürlich gerne ein Polizeiboot zur Verfügung gestellt hat gegen hinreichend
Geld und bereit war irgendwie, hey, hier, super,
wir schippern euch gerne über den See in einem Polizeiboot und hatte auch Tarife
dafür und alle Leute wussten davon, Weil ganz offensichtlich,
ich habe irgendeinen gefragt und dann sagte ich, ja geh mal zum Polizeichefleitenboot,
wenn jemand was braucht.
Hätte ich gesagt, ich muss irgendwie 20 Bewaffnete ins Nachbarland bringen oder
so. Oder ich hätte wahrscheinlich auch sagen können, ich habe hier einen Drogentransport.
So hätte der wahrscheinlich auch, dann wären die Preise höher gewesen wahrscheinlich.
Dann hätte er einen Cut gewollt.
Aber ich hätte wahrscheinlich von dem Polizeichef hätte man da,
ja, was auch immer für Dienste einfach kaufen.
Solange man es bezahlen kann.
Solange man es bezahlen kann, ja.
Ja, okay, also das ist jetzt sozusagen Venezuela in a nutshell,
wie es sich jetzt seit den 90ern nicht so besonderlich gut entwickelt hat und
da schaffe es halt so ein kurzes Aufflammen einer sozialistischen Illusion.
Er war ja dann auch so neben Fidel Castro so einer der Posterboys dieser internationalen
sozialistischen Linken.
Sag ich mal. Also wurde ja dann auch so ein bisschen verklärt,
hat sich dann aber eben schnell und das bringt glaube ich dann auch das Amt
und diese Rolle als Lichtbringer irgendwo mit sich.
Irgendwann halten sich die Leute auch einfach für die Größten und dann wird
es halt auch einfach nur noch korrupt. Und das war dann bei Chavez halt auch
nicht anders und mit Maduro kam eben auch noch dazu, dass er das besonders schlecht geleitet hat.
Mittlerweile ist auch die Ölproduktion Venezuelas zurückgegangen,
weil sie einfach ihr Zeug nicht mehr gemaintained bekommen.
Auf 10 bis 15 Prozent vom Höhepunkt.
Der Höhepunkt lag glaube ich mal irgendwo bei 3 Millionen Barrels.
Jetzt sind es irgendwo 300 bis 500.000.
Genau, also das muss man jetzt auf jeden Fall auch nochmal klar machen.
Also Venezuela ist auch Teil der OPEC,
also dieses Verbundes ölproduzierender Staaten, in dem nicht alle ölproduzierenden
Staaten drin sind, vor allem ist USA und Kanada nicht Teil davon,
aber halt Iran und Saudi-Arabien, Russland und so weiter.
Und vor allem gilt Venezuela als das Land mit den größten nachgewiesenen Ölvorkommen auf dieser Welt.
Also mehr noch als Saudi-Arabien, mehr noch als Russland schlummert unter dem
Land und vor allem unter dem Meer Venezuelas und teilweise auch vor der Küste
des nächsten Nachbarlandes.
Ecuador.
Nee, nicht nach Osten. Was war denn da nochmal das nächste? Entschuldigung.
Da kommt dann Kolumbien.
Kolumbien ist ja im Westen. Ich rede von Guyana.
Achso, Guyana.
Ja, da gab es ja dann auch immer wieder so Drohungen, dass dann irgendwie das
venezolanische Militär da in Guyana Landgrabbing macht und so weiter.
Ich glaube, das ist derzeit erstmal nicht mehr eine Diskussion.
Ja, wir sind einfach nicht dazu in der Lage.
Ja, mittlerweile nicht mehr. Also Guyana wäre jetzt auch nicht in der Lage gewesen,
sich gegen Venezuela zu verteidigen.
Von daher war das schon immer noch so ein Thema. Aber ich glaube,
das ist jetzt gerade mal nicht die Agenda.
Auf jeden Fall, ich wollte darauf hinaus, große Ölvorkommen.
Jetzt ist es aber auch so, Ölvorkommen ist nicht gleich Ölvorkommen.
Also die Länder, die heutzutage Öl produzieren, tun das alle aus einer anderen
geologischen Situation heraus.
In den USA ist es vor allem derzeit dieses Fracking, was eine ganz andere Art von Öl produziert.
Also da kommt so dieses Light Oil bei raus, das ist schon fast super flüssig,
das ist schon fast so eine wässrige Lösung, die dann eben entsprechend mit Raffinerien
aufgearbeitet werden muss. Vinodulele hat genau das Gegenteil.
Das ist nämlich dieses dicke, schlackige, fast schon gummihafte Öl.
Es gibt dann auch so in der Mitte eben so das, was man sich vielleicht so klassisch
als Öl vorstellt, so wie man es sich auf einen Salat gießt, so in der Konsistenz.
Das ist auch alles förderbar, aber auch nicht besonders einfach und da braucht
man auch spezialisierte Raffinerien dazu.
So, ich habe jetzt nicht die komplette Landkarte vor meinem geistigen Auge,
wo jetzt welche Öltypen so verbreitet sind, aber es ist auf jeden Fall in dem
Kontext der Betrachtung hier dieses US-Vorstoßes auch nochmal ganz interessant
zu sehen, dass es an der Südküste der USA, also Texas,
eine ganze Reihe von Ölraffinerien gibt, die derzeit gar nicht mehr so im Betrieb
sind oder beziehungsweise nicht ausgelassen sind.
Sind und die aber sehr wohl für eben texanisches Öl, was eine ähnliche Qualität
teilweise hat, ausgerichtet sind.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht genau, ob das texanische Öl identisch ist,
aber auf jeden Fall gibt es dort Raffinerien, die mit dem venezolanischen Öl
theoretisch was anfangen können.
Das muss man nur mal so als Hintergrund darstellen.
Um jetzt mal zu schauen, was eigentlich passiert ist.
So, jetzt haben sie also die Pläne der USA, naja, ich hätte fast gesagt,
geändert ist natürlich Quatsch, weil wenn man sich jetzt anschaut,
was sie getan haben, ist klar, dass sie das von Anfang an wollten oder dass
sie das zumindest von Anfang an in Betracht gezogen haben, weil so krass,
wie sie jetzt Venezuela ausspioniert haben und wo sie da Informationen haben
und wie sie das militärisch alles geplant haben, Das machst du nicht in zwei Wochen.
Nicht vor Weihnachten sagt der Trump, lass mal angreifen. Und die so, ja okay.
Sondern das ist das Ergebnis einerseits wahrscheinlich schon einer jahrzehntelangen
Beobachtung und Infiltration des Landes, die es sicherlich in irgendeiner Form
gegeben hat, aber eben auch eine gezielte Vorbereitung auf genau dieses Szenario.
Ja und dann haben wir das ja alle halb mitbekommen, nehme ich mal an.
Es wurde dann der Befehl erteilt, Maduro dort festnehmen zu lassen.
Und ja, das war jetzt und das ist jetzt auch wirklich nur eine rein militärische Perspektive.
Also aus militärischer Sicht war das eine Meisterleistung. Also da haben die
Amerikaner mal allen wieder gezeigt, wer hier sozusagen den Hängsten hat.
Wo der Hammer hängt.
Ja genau, also das muss man schon sagen, aber dafür haben sie einfach die Ausbildung,
dafür haben sie die Spezialisierung, dafür haben sie das Personal,
dafür haben sie auch das Gerät.
Ja und es gab dann ein paar Luftschläge, sie haben glaube ich so vier,
fünf, sechs größere militärische Zentren,
Hafen, Flughafen und noch ein paar andere Orte direkt sehr zielgenau bombardiert,
unter anderem eben auch da in der Nähe dieses Bunkerbereichs,
wo sie wohl wussten, dass Maduro sich dort aufhält.
Das dürfte dann vor allem viele von diesen Kubanern getroffen haben oder andere Eliteeinheiten.
Ich weiß natürlich nicht, wer da jetzt in welcher Baracke geschlafen hat,
aber wenn man sich jetzt die Vorher-Nachher-Luftbilder dieser Region anschaut,
dann sieht man, dass da eben gezielt zwei, drei, vier Hallen in diesem gesamten
Komplex, der dazu gehört, dass die gezielt zerstört wurden und zwar extrem surgical.
Also das ist wirklich so von einzelnen Hallen nicht so ruhig geblieben und die
Hallen daneben waren vielleicht nicht unversehrt durch Schrapnell und so weiter,
aber definitiv kein Ziel gewesen.
Und ja, dann ist es ihnen offenbar auch gelungen, die Luftabwehr weitgehend auszuschalten.
Also es gab dort eben die vorhin schon erwähnten S-300 Systeme,
aber auch so Buk-Systeme, also im Wesentlichen russische Luftabwehrtechnik.
Die entweder nicht in Betrieb war oder dann außer Betrieb genommen wurde,
sodass es also den Amerikanern dann möglich war,
innerhalb, und das Ganze hat sich ja glaube ich innerhalb von drei,
vier Stunden abgespielt, mit mal so einer ganzen Horde von Chinook-Hubschraubern da einzureiten.
Also es gab das eine Video, da habe ich irgendwie so acht oder zehn oder so gezählt.
Sind also da mit Spezialtruppen reinmarschiert, haben sich Zugang zu diesem
Bunker verschafft, haben irgendwie Maduro und seine Frau aus dem Schlaf geholt,
eingeladen, ab in den Hubschrauber, zack wieder raus, ohne dass irgendwas abgeschossen wurde.
Die venezolanische Armee hat's.
Aber auch probiert. Also es gab durchaus auch so Videos von.
Ja, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was da zum Einsatz kam. Es hat auf jeden Fall nicht gut getroffen.
Also erstmal offensichtlich, weil es ja offensichtlich nichts erwischt worden.
Aber man hat dann auch gesehen, dass die irgendwo, Kraut und Rüben,
da irgendwo explodiert sind.
Aber es sah nicht wirklich nach einer aktiven Luftverteidigung aus.
Das ist schon überraschend, muss ich sagen. Ich habe nicht gedacht,
dass es jetzt so scheiße läuft für Venezuela an der Ich.
Denke aber auch die Amerikaner hatten auch Glück. Also es war nicht jetzt alleine nur Glück,
aber so eine Operation gerade gegen einen Regierungsoberhaupt.
Wir haben halt gesehen, dass dasselbe nicht funktioniert hat bei Saddam Hussein oder Gaddafi.
Alle Versuche dort, den auch per Luftschlag auszuschalten oder der Versuch,
damals die iranischen Geiseln zu befreien, also die amerikanischen Geiseln in der Botschaft,
In Teheran, so damals unter Carter, wo was da so spektakulär schief gelaufen ist.
Oder so mal ja Einsatz hier Black Hawk Down.
Ja, Black Hawk Down. Also sowas
kann halt einfach auch ganz schnell schief gehen, weil Militär bei allem,
wenn man so sieht oder glaubt, es geht halt immer unglaublich viel schief beim Militär.
Immer so. Also es läuft eigentlich nie genau nach Plan.
Vor allen Dingen, weil du eben auch es mit einem Gegner zu tun hast,
der dann manchmal Dinge tut, die du nicht auf dem Radar hattest.
Aber auch eine These, die geäußert
wurde, dass die USA jetzt durch den Kampf, Krieg gegen den Terror.
Militär eben auf solche Kommando-Aktionen hin eben extrem trainiert hat.
Wie macht man sowas, dass solche Raids, dass es da jetzt eben sehr qualifizierte,
erfahrene Operator gibt.
Aber dass man jetzt daraus schließen kann, dass die USA in der Lage sind,
sowas zu wiederholen oder quasi jeden Staatschef auf der Welt einfach auf diese
Art und Weise wegzuschnappen.
Das wäre eine Überinterpretation. Und oft gehen solche Dinge halt auch,
kannst du halt einmal machen, weil niemand damit rechnet.
Aber jetzt natürlich jeder Diktator, so auf der Liste dann, ich meine,
wer sind die Nächsten, stehen ja eine ganze Reihe von. Kastro-Ländern.
Kastro-Ländern.
Ja, also Kuba ganz vorne, weil auch natürlich Marco Rubio als Ex-Kubaner ganz
gerne seine Heimat, sein Heimatland befreien würde.
Also insofern ja, plus diverse andere Diktatoren oder ähm,
Da unten. Und aber letztlich natürlich, klar,
regt es die Fantasie an und lässt bei verschiedenen Leuten, die möglicherweise
betroffen sein könnten, ungute Gefühle aufkommen.
Aber wie gesagt, man sollte es nicht überinterpretieren.
Also nur weil es jetzt einmal so perfekt geklappt hat, heißt das nicht,
dass sie das jetzt wiederholen könnten.
Ich meine, Osama Bin Laden war natürlich auch so eine Aktion.
Das ist vielleicht nicht ganz vergleichbar.
Das hat halt 10 oder 15 Jahre gedauert, bis sie ihn hatten.
Also immerhin, Gott sei Dank, müssen sie jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit irgendwelche
Leute im High-Profile-Bereich da aus der Welt rausnehmen. Naja, egal.
Auf jeden Fall, trotz alledem, eine gelungene Militäraktion.
Hätte auch schief gehen können, ist aber nicht. Und von daher haben sie natürlich
jetzt so einen Schockeffekt erzeugt auf vielen Ebenen.
Ein paar davon müssen wir ja hier auf jeden Fall mal ansprechen.
Vor allem sicherlich in Venezuela, wo jetzt mittlerweile seine Vizepräsidentin,
zumindest vorübergehend offiziell ist, ist ja ja sozusagen nicht weg,
sondern nur nicht da. Wurde sie also jetzt.
Vereidigt, wurde dann auch gleich beglückwünscht vom chinesischen,
russischen und iranischen Botschafter des Landes, um mal gleich klarzumachen,
wie die Allianzen da jetzt stehen, nämlich genauso wie vorher auch.
Und Trump posaunt natürlich jetzt rum und findet sich geil und,
Ja, lässt noch nicht mal auch nur einen Zweifel daran, was eigentlich sein Ziel ist.
Nämlich er will jetzt irgendwie das Öl da kontrollieren und labert davon,
sie würden jetzt irgendwie, ja, they're running the country now und alles müsste
jetzt irgendwie hier nach unserer Pfeife tanzen.
Und das ist natürlich bemerkenswert, weil sie natürlich nicht einen einzigen
Soldaten auf venezuelanischem Land haben und nicht in irgendeiner Form irgendwas
wirklich jetzt kontrollieren, aber dann doch halt schon auch irgendwie,
weil sie natürlich jetzt im Prinzip zwei Drohungen ausgesprochen haben, die real ist.
Nämlich erstens, wer jetzt nicht spurt und.
Mal Politik macht, wie wir uns das vorstellen, nämlich die ganze Kohle jetzt
hier für Trump, den können wir jetzt genauso hier wieder wegbombardieren.
Alles überhaupt gar kein Problem. Habt ihr ja gesehen, wisst ihr Bescheid.
Und das Zweite ist, dass sie das Land jetzt quasi in Schwitzkasten nehmen können
durch ihre Seeblockade.
Sie sind da mit ihrer riesigen Armada davor und sie lassen jetzt die Tanker
nicht durch, beziehungsweise leiten die jetzt einfach in die USA,
um mal so hier, Tanker mit venezolanischem Öl, ja kein Problem hier,
Texas, fahr doch mal dahin,
und geben ja auch offen zu, dass sie dann die Kohle dem Staatshaushalt,
also Trump wahrscheinlich, hinzufügen.
Ja, also der sozusagen der letzte Stand der Dinge und es klingt halt erstmal auch gar nicht so blöd.
Also es hat ein paar abgesehen davon, dass das Ganze komplett illegal ist.
Ja, das muss man auch mal dazu sagen.
Weil ein Twist ist,
die Regierung Maduro ist seit den letzten Wahlen wegen Wahlbetrug von allen
westlichen Ländern einfach nicht anerkannt, unter anderem von den USA.
Das heißt, die USA stellen sich auf den Standpunkt, das ist gar kein Staatschef,
das ist ein gewöhnlicher Krimineller, der keine Legitimation hat.
Da ist auch was dran.
Ja, auf der anderen Seite ist es schon so, dass es darauf ankommt,
jetzt auch völkerrechtlich, wer jetzt die effektive Kontrolle ausübt über ein Land.
Also du kannst jetzt nicht mit einer Exilregierung, also so wie du auch mit
einer Exilregierung in den seltensten Fällen irgendwelche bindenden Deals machen,
dann kommst du darauf an, wer kontrolliert eigentlich das Land.
Und unabhängig davon, woher er jetzt die Person, die Legitimation bezieht,
wenn er das Amt ausübt und die Kontrolle hat,
dann kannst du zwar jetzt juristische Fiktion bauen, dass er das nicht ist.
Aber das ist halt so ein formales Argument, was nicht wirklich zieht,
aber erstmal zumindest eins,
wo viele Leute sagen, ja macht ja Sinn, der wurde ja nie wirklich gewählt.
Also insofern gar nicht so dumm, diese Argumentation.
Jetzt mit dem Öl, was jetzt konkret passiert,
so als erster Schritt, das war das letzte Ding, was ich gestern gehört habe,
was auch die US-Regierung so bekannt gegeben hat.
Sie haben jetzt einen Deal mit Venezuela wohl, mit der Nachfolgerin,
dass Venezuela jetzt irgendwie was zwischen 50 und 100 Millionen Barrel Öl an die USA liefert.
Und die USA verkauft es dann auf dem Weltmarkt zum Marktpreis und nicht zum,
ich meine im Moment verkauft Venezuela ja zum diskontierten Ölpreis an China
und an wen auch immer der bereit ist,
jetzt so Problemöl zu kaufen.
Aber weil das eben Problemöl ist, müssen sie halt einen Discount geben,
so wie Russland auch einen Discount geben muss und so wie Iran auch einen Discount
geben muss, weil es halt sanktioniertes Öl ist.
Was die Amerikaner jetzt aber quasi machen ist, sie entsanktionieren das Öl,
sodass es dann einen Marktpreis erzielt wird.
Das heißt, dass es dann ein Mehr an Geld da ist.
Die USA packen das dann in einen Fonds und zwacken selber für sich was davon
ab, wobei unklar ist, wie viel.
Und dass es auch überhaupt keine gesetzliche Grundlage dafür gibt,
aber das ist sozusagen jetzt der Plan.
Also USA hält das Geld und gibt dann für bestimmte Zwecke, gibt es dann Teile von dem Geld frei,
wenn die venezuelanische Regierung entsprechend spurt.
Das ist der Plan im Moment, wie es läuft.
Also Erpressung sozusagen.
Ja, Erpressung, wobei es am Ende darauf ankommen wird, wie viel die Amerika
jetzt für sich selbst abzweigt von dem Geld.
Also wenn jetzt nach Venezuela einfach nichts kriegt so am Ende des Tages oder
nur ein Bruchteil davon,
dann wird das eine andere Reaktion hervorrufen, als wenn die USA jetzt 98% der
Einnahmen dann nach Venezuela geben und irgendwie 3% Verwaltungsgebühr oder so.
Was sie mit Sicherheit nicht tun werden.
Aber das heißt, das wird ein wichtiger Punkt sein.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es natürlich auch vollkommen illegal,
sich dem Land das Geld wegzunehmen oder die Einnahmen wegzunehmen und dann das
Land darüber zu regieren,
indem man dann ihnen ihr eigenes Geld stückweise zurückgibt.
Auf der anderen Seite,
Das Land ist ja Korruptionswelt.
Ja, nicht Weltmeister, aber Amerika-Meister. Das ist das korrupteste Land nach
Transparency in Amerika kontinental seit ein paar Jahren.
Was das für was heißen angeht.
Das heißt, man könnte jetzt durchaus auch argumentieren und sagen,
naja, macht vielleicht Sinn, wenn irgendjemand ein Auge auf das Geld hat,
dass das jetzt nicht von den.
Ganzen korrupten,
von der jetzigen korrupten Regierung quasi für was auch immer verwendet wird. Aber ...
Dass, sagen jetzt die amerikanische Regierung oder Trump,
dass die dort eine Variante finden, die im Sinne der Venezuelaner tatsächlich ist,
das ist eher unwahrscheinlich.
Und dann, der größte Haken an dem Problem ist, dass es nicht unbedingt zur Stabilität führen wird.
Es ist zwar erstmal, sieht es cleverer aus, als das, was die USA im Irak gemacht
haben, mit dem sie die gesamte im Irak, die gesamte ehemalige Regierung,
die De-Barsifizierung, in dem sie die ganze Bars-Partei alle gefeuert hatten
und dann niemand da war, der wusste, wie man ein Land betreibt,
plus halt auch noch im Besitz von Waffen.
So, das ist suboptimal, so, wenn du alle rausschmeißt. Trump,
Macht jetzt genau das Gegenteil, es wird niemand rausgeschmissen.
Hauptsache ihr tut, was ihr euch sagt.
Im Moment, außer Maduro und seiner Frau, ist alles so, wie es war.
Die Partei existiert weiter, das Militär hat all seine Waffen und Truppen.
Die Nachbarschaftsmilizen sind nach wie vor da, das ganze Unterdrückungsregime.
Die Oppositionellen sitzen noch immer im Gefängnis, die gewählten Führer sind
immer noch im Exil. also es gibt.
Nichts ändert sich.
Das einzige ist halt jetzt das mit dem Geld dass der Hebel der da ist dass wenn jetzt,
die USA, Trump, nicht genug Geld überweist, dann bricht halt einfach alles zusammen.
Weil wie gesagt, es wird unglaublich viel subventioniert. Es gibt kaum wirtschaftliche Aktivitäten.
80% der Nahrungsmittel müssen importiert werden.
Wegen der Blockade kommt dann jetzt auch nichts aus Kuba oder sonst wo an.
Das heißt, da bahnt sich jetzt quasi auch eine potenzielle humanitäre Katastrophe.
Die das Land ja ohnehin schon hat.
An die, also es ist jetzt schon ziemlich schlimm, aber das kann halt alles nochmal
viel, viel schlimmer werden.
Und im Grunde genommen wäre es wahrscheinlich auch, schlimmer geworden,
auch ohne, dass die USA jetzt irgendwas gemacht hatten.
Ich meine, unter Biden, Biden hatte ja dann gesehen, dass man da was tun muss
und hatte dann bestimmte Sanktionen wieder gelockert.
Also es ist eh die Amerikaner halt lockern und sanktionieren und lockern und
sanktionieren und je nachdem.
Also da war auch Chaos. Und das hat halt dazu geführt, dass zumindest unter
beiden es wieder etwas besser wurde, was die Ölförderung und die Ölexporte und Öleinnahmen angeht.
Also unter beiden wurde dann ihnen quasi eine Lifeline geworfen.
Was jetzt passiert? Ja, gute Frage. So kann man,
ein Land von außen regieren, in dem man einfach Einfluss auf den Geldstrom hat, aber ansonsten nichts.
Ja, ich habe da so ein bisschen meine Zweifel.
Also eigentlich, wenn du Regime-Change machst,
müsstest du wenigstens die Top 300 oder je nachdem Top N, sag ich mal,
musst du wenigstens dann austauschen gegen Leute.
Aber es geht ja nicht um Regime-Change, sondern es geht ja sozusagen nur darum,
den Geldfluss zu changen.
Ja.
Na, offensichtlich. Eine andere Strategie kann ich da jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht
drauf rauslesen, weil es gibt ja noch nicht mal die Ansage, dass ich irgendwas
verbessern soll in dem Land.
Es geht ja nur darum, dass die Amerikaner die Kontrolle über die Ölproduktion
bekommen und er möchte jetzt gerne das amerikanische Unternehmen dort investieren
und die brachliegende Infrastruktur wieder aufbauen.
Da würde ich auch mal Zweifel anmelden, dass das eine viable Strategie ist.
Erstens, das ist arschteuer.
Zweitens, die waren da ja schon mal und haben alles irgendwie entzogen bekommen
in dem Moment, wo sich die Machtverhältnisse wieder geändert haben.
Trump ist im allerbesten Fall noch drei Jahre im Amt.
Danach vollkommen unklar. jede Maßnahme, selbst wenn sie morgen begonnen werden
könnte, was ja vollkommen illusorisch ist,
würde erst in zehn Jahren in irgendeiner Form Früchte tragen und solche langfristigen
Investitionen macht halt so ein Unternehmen nicht.
Also diese Ansage von der Trump-Regierung mit, die sollen jetzt nicht mal alle
mal springen, aber weiß ich nicht so richtig, ob die da ihren Geldbeutel aufmachen.
Vielleicht wird es irgendeinen Verrückten geben, der es macht,
aber das scheint mir nicht sinnvoll zu sein.
Zumal ich meine diese,
Regierung jetzt in Venezuela. Ich meine nicht, dass sie jetzt viel an Legitimationen
hatte vorher, aber wenn sie jetzt sozusagen auch noch auf der einen Seite behaupten,
ja wir sind hier die bolivarische sozialistische Revolutionsregierung und wir
sind ja fürs Volk, aber die Kohle kriegen jetzt die Amerikaner und ansonsten
bleibt aber auch die Unterdrückung und die schlechte Versorgung des Landes bleibt alles gleich.
Das ist ja sozusagen das Premiumrezept, um jeglichen Bürgerkrieg wieder sofort
ausbrechen zu lassen und dann ist halt richtig Untergang und dann gibt es doch mehr Flüchtlinge.
Ja, nicht nur das. Es dürfte auch innerparteilich zu massiven Zerreißproben führen,
weil es gibt dann eben dort auch in dieser sozialistischen Partei die Ideologen, die sagen,
für die nach wie vor die Amerikaner das Böse sind.
Und wo man Himmel und Hölle in Bewegung setzen wird, um dafür zu sorgen,
dass das nicht so läuft, wie die Amerikaner das gerne hätten.
Ja, plus dann eben die Opposition.
Also letztlich ist ja die Frage immer, für Investitionen auch ist politische Stabilität.
Und in der Regel die stabilsten Systeme sind meistens so Demokratien,
die funktionieren mit einer entsprechenden auch Verwaltung und Gesetzen und
wo man sich eigentlich darauf verlassen kann.
Das sind einfach die stabilsten Systeme, aber auch jetzt Diktaturen oder autoritäre
Systeme können halt sehr stabil sein,
wenn es einfach keine Alternative gibt zu einem aktuellen System.
Was wir gesehen haben, so in Libyen oder Irak,
wie letztlich Alternativen zu einem starken Führer erstmal nicht wirklich funktioniert haben.
Und ja also nach Stabilität sieht es nicht aus unbedingt und nach Regime-Change
sieht es auch nicht aus im Moment und wenn man das jetzt.
Gut spielt, bringt man dann, lässt man die erstmal jetzt,
walten, die Nachfolgerinnen, um dann
Wahlen zu organisieren und dann eine Machtübergabe zu organisieren, aber.
Die Führungsriege, die haben alle schon Konten in der Schweiz,
die aufgeflogen sind im Rahmen von Swiss Leaks und so kam halt raus auch,
dass die halbe Parteiführung Nummern konnten, also die Venezuelanische Parteiführung,
alle Nummern konnten in der Schweiz hatten.
Und das gäbe denen die Möglichkeit jetzt, was aber auch nicht ungewöhnlich ist,
in Chile gesehen, quasi so einen Übergang hinzubekommen, wo die Mitglieder der
aktuellen Regierung, die natürlich auch viele politische Morde,
Folter und so weiter sich schuldig gemacht haben,
die man gerne vor Gericht sehen würde.
Und die wissen, dass wenn die Opposition einfach drankommt, sie den Rest ihres
Lebens im Gefängnis sitzen, so haben die jetzt Zeit,
sie für sich Amnestie raus zu verhandeln oder wenigstens genug Geld noch beiseite
zu bringen in den nächsten Monaten, um dann im Exil irgendwo bequem leben zu können.
Das ist das, was da jetzt gerade abläuft.
Aber ja, Stabilität sieht anders aus.
Auf der anderen Seite muss man sagen, ja, sieht jetzt nicht so aus,
als wenn da jetzt gerade Massenproteste sofort ausgebrochen sind oder die Opposition
das irgendwie jetzt die Chance ergriffen hat.
Was aber auch daran liegt, dass die USA jetzt keinerlei Unterstützung bisher
für die Opposition wirklich geäußert haben.
Und da gibt es ja mehrere Kandidaten, unter anderem eben die Friedensnobelpreisträgerin,
wo dann auch gemutmaßt wurde, dass Trump die allein deswegen nicht will,
weil sie den Friedensnobelpreis gekriegt hat und er nicht.
Und sie ist dann sogar so weit gegangen, dass sie ihren Nobelpreis quasi Trump gewidmet hat.
Das reicht ihm nicht. Sie hätte ihn gar nicht erst annehmen dürfen.
Ja, sie hätte ihn gar nicht erst annehmen dürfen. Sie hätte sagen müssen,
nee, ich nehme den nicht an, weil eigentlich steht der Trump zu und dann wäre
es vielleicht anders gelaufen.
Wobei am Ende des Tages auch Leute sagen, das ist nur eine Geschichte,
darauf kommt es nicht wirklich an. Es geht hier um Geld und Öl.
Auf jeden Fall ist er nicht bereit, der eigentlichen Führerin der Opposition
hier eine Machtoption zu verschaffen, was er ja theoretisch machen könnte.
Aber das würde halt bedeuten, man müsste sich wirklich mit dem gesamten Militär
auseinandersetzen und das will er halt auch nicht.
Also ich frage mich halt vor allem ist diese Strategie,
die wir jetzt meinen, herauslesen zu können.
Ist das, also erstmal, ist das die Strategie?
Und zweitens, seit wann existiert die, wenn sie das ist?
Also existiert die jetzt sozusagen so als Afterthought? Oder ist das,
haben wir jetzt hier irgendwie wieder das mit vierdimensionalem Schachspiel
zu tun? Ich habe so ein bisschen meine Zweifel.
Ich habe so den Eindruck, das Ganze ist allein wieder aus so Show-Off,
Diplomatie geboren mit so dem einfachen Ziel, so Hauptsache irgendwie Öl,
Hauptsache irgendwie Geldquelle und das Land ist mir egal,
und ich will aber jetzt hier auch mal meine Allüren nochmal zur Schau stellen,
dass jetzt alle ordentlich Angst haben müssen, weil wir sind jetzt hier die
Nummer 1 in Amerika und uns gehört hier der komplette Nord,
Zentral- und Südkontinent.
Ja, also als,
Reality-Show hat die neue Staffel so auf jeden Fall wieder so viel Aufmerksamkeit und gute Quoten.
Die neue Staffel hat geliefert. Es ist auf jeden Fall ein Quotenknüller und
sozusagen der Maduro-Twist jetzt hat auf jeden Fall für viel Presse und Aufmerksamkeit gesorgt.
Und das, was dann so, das formiert sich irgendwie erst gerade.
Ich glaube nicht, ich denke, es gab irgendwie...
Ist das Ansätze eines Plans? Wie hätte Trump damals das noch bei der Gesundheitspolitik gesagt?
Ich erinnere gerade den Spruch nicht.
Also jedenfalls gab es wahrscheinlich Ansätze eines Plans oder Ideen für einen Plan,
bevor das losgelegt wurde.
Aber ansonsten, denke ich, fährt man mehr oder weniger ohne Plan.
Wobei Plan in der Politik sowieso immer überschätzt wurde.
Das war in den 1970er Jahren, war Planung sehr in, da hat man überall Planungsstäbe geschaffen.
Und irgendwie, weil man dachte, als kybernetisches Modell, so ein Staat,
könne man dann mit Planung deutlich mehr hinbekommen.
Also jetzt politischer Planung.
Ich rede jetzt nicht von Stadtplanung oder so.
Und hat sich alles gezeigt, war am Ende, also mit Plan, waren die Ergebnisse
nicht besser als ohne Plan.
So als wenn man immer nur reagiert hat, weil wenn du einen Plan hast und es läuft nicht nach Plan,
dann neigst du dazu, trotzdem erstmal an dem Plan länger festzuhalten,
als es vielleicht gut wäre.
Und ja.
Also ich würde da mal einwerfen, dass China einen Plan hat und damit auch gar
nicht so schlecht fährt.
Also auf jeden Fall haben die mehr einen Plan als Europa und die USA zusammen.
Ja, wobei das auch ein bisschen was damit zu tun hat,
dass du in China auch eine einschlägige Ausbildung brauchst,
wenn du einen Posten in der Politik haben willst.
Ja, das mag sein. Die schaffen dann auch die Voraussetzungen dafür,
dass das funktionieren kann.
Ich will jetzt auch nicht China über den grünen Klee loben. Da ist definitiv
auch nicht alles im grünen Bereich. Gar keine Frage.
Aber in Bezug auf den Plan kann man jetzt nicht sagen, dass sie keinen haben.
Erstmal ist das ja ohnehin ihr Ding. Aber die Langfristigkeit,
mit der Ziele verfolgt werden, ich glaube, das hast du so nicht.
Ich meine, die Frage ist, gut, das lässt sich nicht allgemein beantworten,
aber so ist, ist kein Plan schlechter als ein schlechter Plan.
Ja.
Das frage ich mich eigentlich auch immer.
Und das lässt sich, glaube ich, nicht allgemein beantworten,
aber wir haben gesehen, dass,
das andere Problem mit Plan ist, der Plan, jeder Plan geht immer nur so und so weit.
Das heißt, es gibt dann irgendwo einen Horizont. Wir haben das ja auch bei Covid gesehen.
Nach drei Monaten war der,
nationale Pandemieplan durchgespielt
und dann hätte eigentlich wieder der Übergang in die wie war das?
Normalität?
In die Zwischenphase, in die inter, wie hieß das noch?
Interpandemische Phase oder so. Interpandemische Phase sozusagen warten auf
die nächste Pandemie, aber war halt nicht so und konntest halt sehen,
in dem Moment, wo der Pandemieplan dann durchgespielt war,
war halt die Verwirrung, also gab es keinen Plan mehr und dann hat man irgendwie
lauter neue Pläne gemacht, die so naja,
funktioniert haben und in der Politik, wenn es so um Regimechange geht oder
so, das sind alles dann Dinge, die sind so komplex erstmal, das heißt,
Überraschungen können immer passieren und in Venezuela jetzt,
aber in Grundmechanismen nach
allem, was man weiß, kann das nicht gut gehen, so wie es gerade läuft.
Es ist zwar ein interessanter Ansatz, innovativer Ansatz,
aber und es ist jetzt auch nicht ausgeschlossen völlig,
dass er irgendwie erfolgreich ist, aber ich halte das für extrem unwahrscheinlich, weil ja,
ein Land auf diese Art und Weise steuern zu wollen, ohne eigene Leute,
Die eigene Kontrollstrukturen und eigenes Sicherheitspersonal.
Ja, dazu kommt natürlich für die USA auch noch die innenpolitische Situation,
weil bisher haben wir ja das Ganze nur von außen betrachtet.
Man kann jetzt nicht unbedingt davon sprechen, dass das Gebaren der Trump-Regierung
sonderlich populär ist in den USA.
Zumindest wenn man den Umfragen trauern darf. Das führt natürlich leider nicht
automatisch dazu, dass die Regierung sich in irgendeiner Form zurücknimmt.
Das ist glaube ich das Ding, dass sich also quasi die Republikaner und der Trump-Komplex
richten sich halt sehr wohl nach Umfragen.
Allerdings erst nur solange sie nicht die Macht haben und in dem Moment,
wo sie die Macht haben, ist es einfach alles komplett entfesselt.
Und deswegen ist das auch alles gerade alles so shocking.
Nur auch die Akzeptanz wird Grenzen haben. Ich denke, da haben wir im Wesentlichen
zwei Lager, die da interessant sind.
Das ist natürlich erstmal, sagen wir mal, the general public.
Klar, ich meine der intellektuelle linke demokratische Teil,
der ist ja ohnehin schon dauerentsetzt, was Trump betrifft, aus gutem Grund.
Dann gibt es halt so diese...
Ich sag mal so, die Swingvoters, die so ein bisschen dazwischen sind,
die Independents in den USA, die in irgendeiner Form, warum auch immer,
halt der Meinung waren, naja, dann probieren wir es doch halt mal mit dem Typen nochmal.
Ist ja letztes Mal schon so gut gelaufen. weil sie ja immer nur aus irgendwelchen
innenpolitischen Eigeninteressen und so weiter machen, so ist das ja bei uns
auch insbesondere diese außenpolitische Dimension,
wird ja in den USA eigentlich bei den Wahlen selten in irgendeiner Form,
relevant, sondern es geht eigentlich immer nur um Innenpolitik und um innere Wahrnehmung, weil,
die meisten Amerikaner erstmal überhaupt gar keine Ahnung haben,
wie die USA weltweit gesehen wird, keine Ahnung haben von der Welt und Außenpolitik einfach,
als nicht sonderlich wichtig angesehen wird.
Trotzdem, da ändert sich natürlich jetzt was. Der interessantere Teil ist natürlich
diese ganze Magerbasis, auf der Trump seine.
Macht basiert hat, insbesondere sein Würgegriff auf die republikanische Partei,
hat eben sehr viel mit dieser Magerbasis zu tun.
Und jetzt ist das eigentlich schon die zweite Attacke auf das,
zugegebenermaßen wirre, aber existierendes Selbstverständnis dieser Mager-Basis.
Das eine war halt so die Epstein-Files, dieses ganze Gezerre da drum,
das hat Trump definitiv schon in irgendeiner Form geschadet.
Alles noch nicht ausreichend, aber da geht so ein bisschen der Lack ab.
Man hat das jetzt schon gesehen an diesen Defections hier von Marjorie Taylor
Greene und solchen anderen Wahnsinnigen,
die halt jetzt jahrelang den Trump-Weg unterstützt haben und jetzt erschreckt
abspringen und fast schon in die Opposition ziehen.
Aber eben jetzt auch diese außenpolitischen Schritte, weil Trump ja unter anderem
mit diesem Versprechen angetreten ist.
Mit mir gibt es jetzt hier keine Kriege mehr und der Frieden wird ausbrechen und überhaupt.
Was passiert genau? Das Gegenteil. Also das kann jetzt schon einiges ins Bröckeln bringen.
Also wenn sie so weitermachen, dann wird das mit diesen Midterm-Wahlen im nächsten
November nichts werden und da läuft natürlich die Trump-Regierung Gefahr,
beide Teile des Kongresses zu verlieren, also sowohl den Senat als auch das
Haus, was bedeuten würde, dass er halt dann so eine richtig offizielle Lame Duck ist.
Das ist Spekulation, wir wissen, die können jederzeit wieder andere Sachen erfinden,
die eine größere Aufregung machen, vielleicht noch einen Krieg vom Zaun brechen,
was ja dann immer ganz gut funktioniert hat,
da ist jede Eskalation möglich, aber derzeit ist es auf jeden Fall innenpolitisch
schwierig zu verkaufen,
den Aufwand zu leisten, jetzt ein komplettes Land durch eine Invasion, durch irgendwie...
Eine andere Form und Weise in Ruhe zu bringen.
Nach Irak und Afghanistan ist einfach hat man einfach keine Lust mehr,
obwohl beides auch absehbar war.
War beides klar, dass,
der Westen oder die USA vor allem nicht genügend Durchhaltekraft haben würden,
um die 40 Jahre, die es braucht,
um einen vernünftigen Regime-Change zu machen,
auch genügend Mittel bereitzustellen und das auf eine Art und Weise zu machen,
die auch effektiv oder effizient ist, so wie man das im Zweiten Weltkrieg gemacht hat.
Japan und Deutschland hat es ja halbwegs recht gut funktioniert.
Österreich auch.
Das war nochmal speziell.
Ja, also wie es jetzt weitergeht, da wird man sehen, ich gehe mal davon aus,
dass irgendwie Öl geliefert werden wird.
Und ich meine, es wird ja ohnehin die ganze Zeit, fahren ja Tanker von Chevron sowieso.
Also es gibt ja da auch Aktivitäten so mit US-Firmen.
Es ist nicht so, dass jetzt Venezuela nur an China und Russland und so verkauft, sondern ja,
es gibt da auch ganz klar Lieferungen über Chevron im Wesentlichen.
Und das wird wahrscheinlich zunehmen die werden dann jetzt auch anderes Öl das andere Problem ist,
dass jetzt die ganzen Öltanker die da rumlagen und auf Öl gewartet haben,
nachdem Maduro dann plötzlich weg war haben sie zwei Tage gewartet haben sich
alle koordiniert und sind alle am selben Tag ausgelaufen in alle Richtungen,
und Soweit ich weiß, sind die meisten auch davon gekommen.
Es waren wohl so um die 20 Schiffe, die da aus Venezuela quasi verschwunden
sind, weil sie gedacht haben...
Wir werden kein Öl laden können und laufen Gefahr, dass unser Schiff hier beschlagnahmt
wird, im Hafen eventuell noch.
Die haben sich dann wohl abgesprochen und gesagt, okay, die USA haben nicht
die Kapazitäten, jetzt alle Schiffe aufzuhalten.
Und ja, soweit ich weiß, ist glaube ich nur eins von denen aus dieser Gruppe,
die dann einfach losgesegelt sind, egal wie viel sie gerade geladen hatten oder nicht geladen hatten,
sind sie halt alle los.
Ja, eins ist auf jeden Fall von den Amerikanern jetzt noch aufgebracht worden
und zwar auf der Rückfahrt nach Russland.
Dieser Tanker kam ursprünglich aus dem Iran, offenbar leer, nach Bella 1.
So hieß das Ding zumindest vorher.
Und ist dann auch eben wohl auch mal kontrolliert worden. Es gab wohl so einen
Kontrollversuch der Amerikaner.
Dem Boarding haben sie dann aber widersprochen. Da gab es dann erstmal noch
keinen Widerstand, wahrscheinlich im Zuge der Gesamtaktivität, die sie dort hatten.
Dann ist dieser Tanker losgefahren, hat sein Tracking ausgeschaltet,
war also quasi nicht mehr offiziell auf den Marine Trackers zu sehen,
bis sie hoch im Norden des Atlantiks waren, in Richtung Russland offensichtlich.
Und sie haben mittlerweile auch ihren Namen gewechselt und sie haben auch ihre
Länderaffiliation gewechselt, was nach internationalem Marinerecht nicht zulässig ist.
Es sei denn, es gab einen Verkauf, den es aber hier nicht gab.
Dann wurde aber jetzt dieser Tanker von den Amerikanern dann noch aufgebracht.
Und das ist ganz interessant, weil sie das von UK aus gemacht haben.
Also auch hier wieder eine höhere Vorbereitungsphase, das ist jetzt nicht so,
das machen wir mal eben, das haben sie mit so einem Coast Guard gemacht,
den sie da verlegt hatten und mit Hubschraubern, die sie auf so einer fahrenden
Plattform stationiert haben.
Die Amerikaner haben ja, abgesehen von ihren Flugzeugträgern,
haben die auch noch so, ich sag mal so fahrende Parkhäuser, so sieht das aus. Ex-Öltanker oft.
Ex-Öltanker, die sie umgebaut haben, da ist da so eine riesige Plattform drauf,
da können sie dann Hubschrauber drauf ballern und damit fahren sie halt irgendwo
hin, wenn sie mal irgendwo Hubschrauber brauchen.
Das kam in diesem Fall auch zum Einsatz und dann sind sie da mit dem Hubschrauber
auch gelandet, haben da irgendwie so mindestens zehn Truppen abgesetzt und die
haben sich dann halt einfach mal dieses Schiffs bemächtigt.
Das ist natürlich jetzt, jetzt sind wir full circle wieder bei Russland,
weil das Ding war zu dem Zeitpunkt unter russischer Flagge.
Ja, also Vermutungen, es gibt jetzt Vermutungen, also was ja wahr ist,
dass das Schiff Richtung Venezuela unterwegs war.
Aber jetzt ohne Öl, das ist eigentlich auch ein riesen Öltanker,
aber leer Richtung Venezuela unterwegs war und dann kehrt gemacht hat.
So 500 bis 1000 Seemeilen vor Venezuela haben die halt umgedreht und sind wieder zurückgefahren.
Beziehungsweise nicht zurück, sondern woanders hin.
Ja, woanders hin, also Richtung, also jedenfalls weg von Venezuela Richtung Norden in den Atlantik.
Und dann soll wohl halt nach diesem Versuch dieser Coast Guard Cutter das Schiff
einfach begleitet haben, also hinterher geschippert sein, relativ langsam.
Weil er aber selbst nicht die Mittel oder Mannschaft hatte, um das Schiff aufzubringen,
sind die quasi Verfolgungsjagd im Schneckentempo. Also der Tanker war etwas
älter und war mit neun Knoten unterwegs.
Das sind so um die 18 kmh ungefähr, während so ein Coast Guard Cutter wahrscheinlich
eine Höchstgeschwindigkeit von über 30 Knoten hat, also über 60 kmh fahren kann.
Und ja, also insofern war es so ein bisschen so eine Verfolgungsjagd im Schneckentempo.
Da gab es, gibt es ja diesen Twitter-Ausdruck, dieses Meme, wo dann irgendwie
so Leute auf diesen amerikanischen,
Krankenfahrstühlen, oder nicht Kranken, sondern diese,
quasi Rollstühle.
Rollatoren oder was?
Ja, wo du schon drin sitzt, aber vor dir so einen Lenker hast,
mit dem du dann so lenken kannst und oft auch.
Und die fahren halt nicht sehr schnell und da gibt es so eine berühmte Filmszene,
ich weiß nicht woher die kommt,
wo dann so irgendwie fünf von diesen Leuten sich eine Verfolgungsjagd liefern,
aber so mit vier kmh oder so.
Und das wurde halt dann, weil die dann quasi drei Tage lang,
vier Tage lang durch den Atlantik geschippert sind.
Ja, die haben wahrscheinlich auch den richtigen Zeitpunkt abgewartet,
dass sie die Unterstützung von den Hubschraubern bekommen.
Genau, und dann die Umbenennung. Gibt es auch irgendeinen Film,
der mir gerade nicht einfällt, wo auch viele Filmszenen, wo dann unterwegs dann
der Schiffsname und die Flagge übergepinselt wird.
Das hatten wir schon öfter.
Und tatsächlich haben die die dabei beobachtet. Es gibt dann tatsächlich Filme
und Fotos davon, wie die dann die russische Flagge auf den Tanker malen.
Und dann soll wohl Russland dem Schiff auch ein U-Boot entgegengeschickt haben,
um das Schiff zu eskortieren.
Aber das U-Boot ist vermutlich zu spät gekommen.
Aber selbst wenn es nicht zu spät gekommen wäre, was hätte denn das U-Boot dann machen sollen?
Also es gibt da die schöne Geschichte, wenn du Auseinandersetzungen zwischen Großmächten hast,
ist das so ein Schachspiel zwischen wer schießt nicht als erstes.
Also jetzt als Beispiel, wenn das U-Boot jetzt angekommen wäre,
hätten die jetzt Soldaten auf dem Schiff platzieren müssen,
wo dann die Amerikaner selber quasi die Ersten hätten sein müssen,
die dann das Feuer eröffnen auf die russischen Soldaten.
Das geht natürlich nicht, weil wegen Atomwaffen und so macht man das nicht.
Umgekehrt, jetzt wenn die Amerikaner da als erstes waren und jetzt auf dem Schiff
stehen, hätten die Russen dann als erstes irgendwie das Feuer eröffnen müssen.
Quasi, ja also diese interessante Regel, ja wer als erster nicht schießt hat gewonnen.
So in dieser Form von Auseinandersetzung und ansonsten ja hätte das U-Boot nicht
viel machen können außer Leute, also russische Soldaten.
An Deck zu packen und die so abzuschrecken, weil mit Torpedos die amerikanische
Küstenwache anzugreifen oder den Tanker zu versenken, ich meine,
das bringt alles nicht.
Und jetzt ist das Schiff wahrscheinlich in Schottland. Und es wurde eben vermutet, dass dort Waffen...
An Bord gewesen sein könnten, dass es sich um eine heimliche Waffenlieferung gehandelt hat.
Da aber nichts entsprechendes bisher jetzt vermeldet wurde,
glaube ich, war es nicht so, weil wenn jetzt das Schiff im Hafen wäre oder,
also mittlerweile weiß man, ob Waffen an Bord waren oder nicht oder die Amerikaner wissen das.
Die Amerikaner wissen das unter Umständen nicht, weil ich meine die Frage ist,
ob sie das dann überhaupt sagen würden. Oder was sie dann damit machen würden.
Weiß man nicht, aber wenn, dann würde es glaube ich auch rauskommen,
weil irgendwelche Reporter, die dann kennen dann jemanden, der dann irgendwie
dabei war und so Dinge sickern halt durch.
Das kann ein paar Wochen dauern, aber selbst, ich meine der Double Tap ist ja
auch durchgesickert zum Beispiel.
Ja, in der amerikanischen.
Ja, das wäre, ich meine das wäre natürlich cool, wenn das Ding irgendwie komplett
voll wäre mit russischem Kriegsequipment und den Tanker, den schicken sie dann
gleich zur Ukraine weiter.
Ja, also noch ein bisschen unklar,
wie das alles dort ausgeht und welche Bedeutung man dem zumuten soll.
Die Shadow Fleet, man kann ja schon davon sprechen, dass dieser Tanker der russischen
Shadow Fleet zugeordnet werden kann.
Warum sollten sie sonst mal eben da eine russische Beflaggung ran machen,
ist natürlich für die Russen jetzt auch nochmal extra peinlich,
weil jetzt verlieren sie auch noch an die Amerikaner ihre Shadow Fleet und jetzt gerade während wir,
Aufnehmen habe ich auch schon wieder die nächste Meldung gesehen,
dass auch die Ukraine einen weiteren Tanker der russischen Shell-Fleet angegriffen
hat und diesmal im Schwarzen Meer, da haben sie ja das schon zweimal gemacht.
Und nicht nur das, sondern sie haben den Tanker auf dem Weg nach Novorossisk,
aber innerhalb einer 30-Meilen-Zone des türkischen Ufers angegriffen.
Da haben sich wohl die Russen gedacht, wenn wir da uns schön an der Küste der
Türken ranschleichen, dann werden sie wohl schon irgendwie nichts machen,
aber die Ukraine scheint an der Stelle weiterhin auf volle Konfrontation zu gehen.
Jetzt wollen wir mal gucken, was das jetzt wiederum für Auswirkungen hat.
Ja, denn eigentlich, weil wir gerade bei Schiffen sind, so vor etwas über einem Jahr,
nämlich so im Dezember 2024, ist ja der russische Frachter Ursa Major im Mittelmeer gesunken,
wo es eine Explosion im Maschinenraum gab.
Und dann sind auch russische U-Boote gekommen und da gibt es Mutmaßungen,
die das dann versenkt haben, das Schiff endgültig.
Und jetzt vor zwei Wochen oder so vermeldete eine spanische Zeitung,
dass sich an Bord eben zwei Atomreaktoren befunden haben für U-Boote,
die wohl für Nordkorea bestimmt waren.
Das ist aber nur eine Vermutung.
Das ist, also es scheint aus zuverlässiger Quelle zu stammen.
Aber der interessante Punkt ist,
dass niemand genau weiß, wer eigentlich dahinter steckt.
Wer hat jetzt Interesse daran, die Lieferung von Atomreaktoren an Nordkorea zu verhindern?
Naja, also alle außer Nordkorea?
Ja, es gab sogar dann die Vermutung, dass Russland selbst dahinter stecken könnte.
An dieser Lieferung?
Ja, die Lieferung selbst.
Na, die kommt doch aus Russland.
Ja, aber dass sie sozusagen eigentlich nicht wirklich liefern wollten.
Ach so, dass sie selber dafür gesorgt haben.
Dass die Lieferung nicht ankommt. Dass sie sozusagen den Deal gemacht haben.
Höhere Gewalt.
Und das Ding ist nämlich, dass die Russen haben halt ihren Teil erfüllt.
Also die Fracht, das Verschiffen ging sozusagen zu, war das Risiko von Nordkorea.
Also das war quasi, der Deal war irgendwie Atomreaktoren ab, was ist das da oben?
Gibt es nicht frei Haus?
Ja, ab Arkangel oder so.
Wird nur bis zum Bordstein geliefert.
Und um den Rest müsst ihr euch selber kümmern. Wir können euch hier,
wir haben ja ein Schiff für euch.
Ist jetzt auch nicht, also dann war auch die Überlegung vielleicht Südkorea,
weil die natürlich besonderes Interesse haben, dass Südkorea davon erfahren hat.
Und dann den Ukrainern Waffen zur Verfügung gestellt haben, weil der Schaden, was wohl auch aufkam,
war, dass wohl die Schäden mit denen eines superkavitierenden Torpedos übereinstimmen.
Das sind halt Torpedos, die...
Eben mit Düsenantrieb im Prinzip, die mit extrem hoher Geschwindigkeit in so einer Vakuumblase,
also von der Spitze, da wird das Wasser quasi verkocht oder Vakuumblase und
die zerstören dann teilweise allein durch die kinetische Energie.
Die haben dann gar nicht einen Sprengkorb, sondern fahren dann mit ein paar
hundert kmh, rammen die dann super kavitierende Torpedos.
Das ist aber jetzt sehr spekulativ.
Das kam dann auf. Es kann auch alles mögliche andere gewesen sein.
Und wenn es aber, also die Debatte war, wenn es eben welche gäbe,
es gibt nicht viele Länder, die welche haben.
Die Russen haben welche und die Amerikaner haben welche und Südkorea hat vermutlich auch.
Weißt du, wer es erfunden hat?
Ne.
Die Firma Deal.
Ah, okay.
Und es gab wohl auch bei den Russen ein ähnliches System, schon aus den 70ern.
Ja, gab es auch schon.
Also wie gesagt, ob das jetzt einer war oder nicht, aber diese Geschichte ist
auf jeden Fall jetzt hochgekocht und dass sich an Bord Teile für Atomreaktoren befanden,
war von Anfang an klar.
Es hieß offiziell, es seien irgendwelche Deckel oder Verschlusskappen für irgendwelche Reaktoren und.
Unklar für welches Land, also jedenfalls nicht für Nordkorea.
Aber dass das Teile für Atomanlagen waren, das war von Anfang an bekannt.
Aber dass es jetzt sozusagen sich um mehr oder weniger komplette Atomreaktoren
für U-Boote gehandelt sollte.
Und dann hieß es wohl auch, dass die Russen dann versucht haben,
irgendwie Spuren zu verwischen, dass sie dort dann das Wrack in die Luft gesprengt
haben oder so hieß es dann noch.
Aber da habe ich jetzt nicht hinterher recherchiert.
Nur, ja, was man glaube ich sagen kann,
so die Russen sehen sich gerade oder vor allem auch die Bevölkerung sieht halt jetzt,
wie schwach Russland eigentlich ist in den letzten zwei Wochen.
Gut, vorher konnten sie den Sturz auch von ihrem Diktator in Syrien, Assad.
Konnten sie nicht verhindern, haben dort quasi ihre wichtigste Militärbasis verloren,
im Mittelmeer, jetzt Maduro und dann aber auch, was natürlich dann passiert.
Viele Leute meinten oder gesehen haben, der Kontrast zwischen dem russischen Versuch,
Selenskyj damals mit der Landung in Hostomel zu entführen oder zu töten.
Und die sind nicht mal vom Flughafen runtergekommen und ein Drittel ihrer Hubschrauber
wurde abgeschossen und der Rest der Truppe dann dort am Flughafen eliminiert.
Und aus dieser viertägigen Special Military Operation sind jetzt fünf Jahre Krieg geworden.
Ja, vier. Also gehen wir jetzt ins fünfte Jahr.
Genau.
Langsam, bald.
Und ja, also dieser Kontrast alleine und dann noch jetzt die letzte Demütigung eben mit, ja,
könnt da russische Flaggen drauf pinseln,
wie ihr wollt oder das interessiert uns knapp die Hälfte und haben das dann trotzdem einkassiert.
Wobei es lange Zeit so aussah, als wenn das Schiff weggekommen wäre.
Da hat niemand mehr mit gerechnet, dass sie das quasi so weit im Norden dann sich holen würden.
Und bisher, was diese Schiffsrates angeht,
sind die rechtlich gesehen nicht unbedingt zu beanstanden, sondern die sind
interessanterweise waren die alle legal.
Entweder, weil die Schiffe keine gültige Registry hatten und damit keine gültige
Versicherung und damit quasi fahren ohne Nummernschild oder halt nicht angemeldet.
Nicht angemeldet, nicht versichert. Und da hat dann völkerrechtlich ist es so,
dass jedes Land der Welt das Recht hat, ein solches Schiff zu boarden und eine
Kontrolle durchzuführen.
Und falls sich irgendwie rausstellt, dass es nicht versichert ist oder technisch
nicht in Ordnung ist oder irgendwie andere Dinge, dann können die das durchaus beschlagnahmen.
Das war so bei dem ersten Öltanker war das ganz klar der Fall.
Das war ein staatenloses Schiff, wenn man so will.
Bei dem zweiten, das war ein regulärer Tanker, der war in Panama registriert.
Und da sah es erstmal so aus, als wenn die USA da möglicherweise einen Fehlgriff
getan haben könnte, weil dieses Schiff war halt ordentlich registriert und versichert,
aber Panama hat sein Okay gegeben.
Generell, Panama hat ein Abkommen mit den USA, dass sie generell alles,
was in Panama registriert ist, auch aufbringen.
Also insofern, weil Panama so, war das zweite Ding auch okay und jetzt der dritte
war dann glaube ich auch wieder eindeutig auch wieder Shadow Fleet.
Ich glaube das Ding war vorher, du meinst den sie jetzt im Atlantik aufgebracht haben?
Achso ja, die, okay.
Das war glaube ich die Panama-Situation und das haben sie ja dann nachträglich
nur versucht anders zu registrieren.
Ja, nee, nee, Bela 1 war auch wieder irgendwie Genea oder irgendeine, die Bela 1.
Ja, aber dann war das diese Fake-Registry, wo es nicht wirklich registriert
war, sondern sie nur gesagt haben.
Ja, genau. Also BELA 1 war auch jetzt insofern legal, weil sie eben auch staatenlos waren.
Und als die Russen das gesehen haben, hatten sie dann schnell versucht,
das Schiff selber unter sich zu registrieren. Aber da ist es eben so,
unterwegs kannst du nicht deine Flagge ändern.
Das ist so ein Grundsatz. Du kannst es eigentlich nur tun, wenn du im Heimathafen
bist, kannst du irgendwie den Namen und die Flagge ändern.
Oder wenn das Schiff tatsächlich verkauft wird und der neue Eigentümer in einem
anderen Land sitzt oder die Firma woanders ihre Schiffe regelt,
dann kannst du das auch machen, wenn es quasi unterwegs ist,
jetzt zum neuen Heimathafen oder so kannst du das schon tun oder wie auch immer.
Ja, jetzt müssen wir langsam mal hier so zum Ende kommen.
Ich denke, das haben wir jetzt alles ausführlich besprochen.
Vielleicht nochmal so ein letzter Blick auf die Situation, was bedeutet das
jetzt für den Krieg und für die Ukraine.
Und man könnte ja vielleicht auch nochmal so leichte Prognosen für dieses Jahr abgeben.
Ist ja immer ein bisschen schwierig mit der Zukunft und so.
Ich denke, man kann festhalten, es wird auch, also wenn wir jetzt nicht eine
große Revolution erleben in den USA, wo von meiner Meinung nach nicht wirklich auszugehen ist,
wird es weiterhin schwierig bleiben, weil es ist irgendwie klar,
worum es Trump geht, um Kohle und sich selbst.
Alles andere ist ihm herzlich egal. Ihm ist auch die Ukraine egal.
Das ist ihm eigentlich eher lästig.
Und er hat auch irgendwie keine große Lust, sich da mit den Europäern auszusetzen.
Das geht ja so weit, dass jetzt sogar diese Drohungen mit Grönland weitergehen.
Ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass das Ganze jetzt eher aus wieder
so einem Moment der Überheblichkeit heraus entstanden ist.
Nichtsdestotrotz steht es im Raum und mittlerweile sind die Europäer auch,
im Übrigen auch vollkommen zurecht,
so weit genervt, dass jetzt schon so Diskussionen losgehen mit,
naja, wenn die jetzt irgendwie anfangen, sich hier Grönland einzuverleiben,
dann ist es das Ende der NATO.
Und ich meine, das kann man ja auch mal so sagen, also Verteidigungsbündnis,
wo jetzt irgendwie innerhalb der Verbündeten das eine Land dem anderen was wegnimmt,
das ist dann auch einfach das Ende dieses Verteidigungsbündnisses.
Die Frage ist nur, wer würde hier mehr verlieren?
Natürlich würden alle erstmal dabei verlieren und Europa würde natürlich die
wichtigsten Partner verlieren, nur geht man ja jetzt auch schon gar nicht mehr
davon aus, dass dieser Partner noch zu irgendwas gut ist.
Nur die neue Dimension, die jetzt hier aufgemacht wird, ist nicht nur zu nichts
gut, sondern er könnte sogar selber verlieren.
Quasi zum Gegner werden.
Es wurde jetzt auch bekannt, dass die Franzosen schon begonnen haben,
Pläne zu entwerfen, um eine Invasion durch die Amerikaner zu begegnen.
Eine Invasion Frankreichs?
Ja, oder Europas oder was.
Oder französisch Guyana oder sowas.
Ja, also jedenfalls die Franzosen machen jetzt ganz klar Kriegspläne und Planungen
und ich denke mal, dass sie nicht die einzigen sein dürften,
die jetzt anfangen realistisch zu überlegen,
was tun wir, was können wir tun, wenn die USA tatsächlich jetzt militärisch
gegen irgendwelche europäischen Länder vorgeht.
Also und ähm,
Ich habe überlegt, okay, was ist, wenn Trump wirklich jetzt Militär nach Grönland
schickt, wobei das eigentlich eine komplett sinnlose Geschichte wäre.
Die haben ja schon eine Basis.
Genau, die könnten da so viele Basen bauen, wie sie wollten.
Es geht ja nicht um Security, es ist nur ein vorgeschobenes Argument.
Ja, wobei es heißt irgendwie ja, dass dann die Chinesen und die Russen dann
irgendwie ein Einfallstor haben,
aber natürlich geht es dann auch wieder um Rohstoffe,
wobei wahrscheinlich auch die Isländer sagen würden, wenn ihr hier eine Mine
oder irgendwie Öl fördern wollt oder so, wenn ihr investieren wollt, das hier zu tun, So,
ja, be my guest. Wobei sie sich dann natürlich vorstellen, dass sie dann nicht
um Erlaubnis fragen müssen.
Aber im Moment ist das auch wieder so eine Nummer, wie dort Förderanlagen für
irgendwas zu errichten,
Minen oder auch, ist in der Gegend
einfach extrem teuer und aufwendig und mühsam und es gibt einen Grund,
warum dort nur was war das, 50.000 Leute insgesamt Grönland leben.
Ich weiß gar nicht, aber viel sind es nicht. Ich schau mal kurz.
Grönland. Wie viele Einwohner.
Offiziell,
Sind es 56.542.
Ja, weniger als Lüdenscheid. Und es gibt keinen Berliner Bezirk, der so klein ist.
Das ist irgendwie Prenzlauer Berg oder so.
Ja, aber in Bezug auf Bevölkerungsdichte ist es halt genau das Gegenteil von Prenzlauer Berg.
Das heißt, sehr viel Land und nachgewiesene oder mindestens vermutete Vorkommen
für so ziemlich alles an Bodenschätzen, was in irgendeiner Form Geld wert ist und es ist halt einfach,
ja, ich meine erst den Planeten ordentlich aufheizen,
alles enteisen und dann Kohle machen.
Es gibt leider Leute, die so kurz denken und das ist halt nun mal die tramsche Realität.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass Europa wirklich in ein Shooting War mit Amerika
gehen könnte oder würde.
Nee, Shooting-War nicht. Ich meine, wenn die Amerikaner jetzt Grönland besitzen
und sagen, das ist jetzt unseres und ihr kommt hier gar nicht hin,
da müsst ihr zuerst schießen,
dann wird es natürlich da nicht zu kommen, weil es wäre ein Himmelfahrtskommando,
aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass...
Es ist dann so um Rammstein und solche Orte und den Frankfurter Flughafen sich
da sehr schnell mal die Besitzverhältnisse ändern.
Ich denke auch, dass das dann wahrscheinlich zur Folge hätte,
dass US-Truppen wahrscheinlich aus Europa rausgeschmissen werden würden.
Was natürlich die Russen total begeistern würden, total feiern würden.
Das heißt, selbst das ist so ein Problem.
Aber ich rechne jetzt nicht damit,
dass Trump Grönland militärisch aktiv werden wird, weil der Fallout davon noch mal gewaltig wird.
Und es hängt natürlich viel davon ab, wie es jetzt mit Venezuela läuft.
Wenn jetzt die nächsten Monate,
also bis zum Sommer, also im Winter willst du da eh nicht nach Grönland hin,
also wenn, dann wäre das eine Sache für den Sommer und je nachdem,
wie sich das bis dahin entwickelt wird.
In Venezuela, davon wird vieles abhängen, ob Trump das irgendwo nochmal probiert oder wiederholt.
Und natürlich auch der Senat und Abgeordnetenhaus, die komplett umgangen oder ignoriert wurden.
Und sogar, was halt auch ein absolutes Unding ist, ist, dass die Demokraten
nicht informiert worden sind vor dem Angriff.
Normalerweise ist es seit Jahrzehnten, Jahrhunderten Tradition,
dass wenn du jetzt einen militärischen Einsatz machst, holst du wenigstens den
Minderheitsführer oder so und dass die mit an Bord sind wenigstens.
Und das ist halt auch nicht passiert und ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass das jetzt auch für Probleme sorgt, innenpolitisch.
Aber ja, es gibt natürlich eine Menge Leute, die...
Die Trump dafür bisher auch bejubeln. Wobei dann auch gesagt wurde,
okay, wir hatten diese Momente auch schon.
Wir hatten angefangen damals, Mission accomplished.
Das war auch das Ding, was ich dann getwittert hatte, war einfach nur,
nachdem das gelaufen ist, Mission accomplished?
Wo stehen wir eigentlich? jetzt oder generell dann in Afghanistan sind ja auch
die Taliban gefallen und dann später dann der Einmarsch in Bagdad und der Sturm
von Saddam Hussein und ja,
alles ist dann irgendwann sauer geworden, ist dann irgendwann ins Gegenteil umgeschlagen.
Die Frage ist, wie lange es dauern wird in Venezuela, bis sich irgendwelche
negativen Auswirkungen zeigen.
Also wenn Sie die Schraube jetzt nicht weiter anziehen, wenn sich vielleicht
negative Auswirkungen zeigen in dem Land, also das auf jeden Fall,
wahrscheinlich jetzt schon der Fall, aber halt nicht so, dass es in den USA
irgendjemand interessiert.
Dann könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, dass sie erstmal Kuba sozusagen anfangen,
zumindest erstmal rhetorisch anzuknussend.
Hast du überhaupt schon von dem Namen Miguel Mario Díaz-Canel Bermúdez gehört?
Nein.
Oder auch einfach nur Miguel Díaz-Canel. Haben ja immer so lange Namen da in
den spanischsprachigen Ländern.
Hatte ich auch nicht auf dem Zeiger. Ist der Nachfolger von Raúl Castro.
Ich bin irgendwie in meinem Kopf die ganze Zeit ausgegangen, dass der Bruder von dem,
Fidel Castro, Raul Castro, immer noch im Amt ist, ist aber nicht mehr.
Tatsächlich ist Herr Dias Canel bereits seit 2019.
Staatspräsident der Republik Kuba. Ich habe von dem Namen bis eben noch nie was gehört.
Das ist ganz interessant. Also ich meine, das muss ich vielleicht mal ein bisschen
Vielleicht sollten wir uns mal mit Kuba beschäftigen.
Das scheint ja dem nächsten Thema sein zu können.
Anyway, ich wollte nur sagen, ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das Interesse Trumps
eher erstmal darin liegt, diese ganze lateinamerikanische Hegemonie da zu deklarieren.
Und vielleicht ist Grönland noch ein zu heißes Eisen.
Auf der anderen Seite darf man jetzt auch, also es ist definitiv Zeit für Planspiele
und da muss man auch so etwas wie Grönland oder einen Rückzug aus Europa mit
reinnehmen und es wird einfach mal höchste Zeit,
dass Europa sich da wappnet.
Nicht nur auf der politischen Ebene.
Es muss auch einfach generell einfach mal über Europa nachgedacht werden.
Auf der einen Seite braucht es einfach ein noch engeres Europa.
Wir müssen auch dringend gegen Orbán und Vizo und andere Vollidioten was machen,
weil es ist natürlich voll Trumpsche Agenda,
diese Kräfte in Europa weiter zu stützen. wie auch die AfD und so weiter.
Und ja, es ist wichtig, dass das da langsam mal einen Sinneswandel einsetzt,
auch wenn das natürlich jetzt erstmal Wunschdenken ist.
Ja, also generell,
so jetzt das, ich sag mal,
20.000 Meter Höhe Bild, so was ich sehe, was im Moment passiert ist,
dass Trump und seine Magergesellen das Game of Empires so explizit spielen.
Das, was im 19.
Jahrhundert gang und gäbe war, da war es völlig normal, ein Land zu überfallen
und sich die Ressourcen einzusacken.
Das machte man.
Ja, ist so.
Aber spätestens mit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg hat man dann festgestellt,
das kann man uns nicht leisten auf Dauer.
Diese Art und Weise, weil mit zunehmender Technologie und Bevölkerung so einfach
die Menge an Zerstörung und der Aufwand,
den man für Krieg treiben muss und das Elendste und das Sterben und so, das war einfach klar,
das übersteigt halt jedes Maß.
Und dann hat man sich überlegt, so wie, wie,
Was können wir denn machen, dass das jetzt aufhört?
Und das hat eben einen riesigen Schub in der Gründung UN.
Und wo man dann versucht hat, quasi, okay, einzige Mittelwege ist eben internationales
Recht zu stärken und zu schaffen.
Und internationale Institutionen, die Konflikte friedlich regeln.
Und das hat zu einem großen Teil auch funktioniert, aber es hat vor allen Dingen
insofern funktioniert, dass niemand mehr hingehen konnte und einfach so sagen, okay,
ich überfalle den jetzt, weil ich das Öl haben will oder weil ich dies habe.
Passiert ist es trotzdem noch, aber man braucht da halt zumindest irgendeinen
Vorwand oder irgendeine Geschichte,
irgendeine Fiktion und Und man musste Supermacht sein dazu.
Das heißt, viele der kleinen Kriege und Auseinandersetzungen wurden halt deutlich
reduziert, weil eben halt dann auch die Supermächte in ihrer Einflusssphäre
einfach das nicht zugelassen haben. Also die Pax Americana oder so.
Selbe wie beim Rom, Pax Romana, der römische Frieden.
Wenn du ein Imperium hast, sorgst du halt dafür, dass deine Kolonien oder deine
Vasallen einfach nicht gegeneinander Krieg führen, weil das ist Verschwendung.
Das willst du halt einfach nicht.
Trump hat jetzt aber offenbar sich gesagt, fuck it, ich sag einfach jetzt, wie es ist.
Auch im Irak wussten alle, es geht ums Öl, nur konnte man nicht darüber reden.
Aber ja, hier jetzt, Trump spricht es einfach aus, aber das ist eben auch ein gewisses Problem,
weil dann natürlich du erstmal intern Opposition kriegst von Leuten,
die einfach sagen, Moment, das ist also das Recht,
vor allen Dingen das Recht, was auch so gestaltet wurde, dass es vor allem zum Vorteil der USA ist.
Das ist ja das Irre, was auch Russland immer vorwirft.
Ja, fuck internationales Recht, das haben es von den Amis und den Europäern geschrieben worden.
Das passt überhaupt nicht zu uns.
Und auf uns ist es teilweise durchaus auch eine berechtigte Kritik.
Aber dann sich hinzustellen und sagen Nicht.
Mal das geht.
Noch. Und das, sagen Sie, sich nicht an seine eigenen Regeln oder ja,
offen sich über seine eigenen Regeln hinweg zu setzen,
das schafft einfach unnötig Widerstand und ich glaube, da wird sich jetzt einfach ich hoffe,
aber ich glaube es auch, dass diese Aktionen halt mehr und mehr Widerstand jetzt
hervorrufen werden von allen Ländern auf der Welt und aber auch in den USA, dass das,
langsam zunimmt und irgendwann dann hoffentlich einen Punkt erreicht, wo,
er nichts mehr tun kann. Teilweise sieht man auch schon an verschiedenen Stellen,
wo er eingehegt worden ist, zum Beispiel mit diesem ersten Double-Tap,
wo man dann, hatte ich ja vorhin schon gesagt, wo man gesagt hat, nee,
das kann man nicht wirklich tun.
Und das Problem ist natürlich, dass andere sich jetzt dann auch auf den Standpunkt
stellen können, so andere Länder und dann einfach sagen können,
wir machen jetzt ähnliches.
Ja, aber ich denke, es wird viel,
Ich meine, es ist ein reines Machtspiel. Und wenn du deine Macht,
die du hast, vielleicht auch zum Einsatz bringen willst, dann musst du auch
bereit sein, dafür zu verzichten.
Und ich glaube, wir sind hier auch oft einfach nicht zu diesem Verzicht bereit.
Ich meine, wer ist das schon gerne?
Und im Falle von Deutschland oder Europa, der EU,
ist natürlich offensichtlich, dass wir hier mit den Amerikanern erstmal auf
die liebgewonnene Sicherheitsgarantie verzichten,
die jetzt ohnehin so ein bisschen weg zu dampfen scheint.
Aber das wäre ja dann, sagen wir mal, so ein bewusster Rauswurf,
wäre ja dann eben auch ein ganz offener Verzicht.
Da hängen ja dann auch gleich wieder, ich weiß noch was für eine Diskussion
war, wenn mal irgendwo Truppenmengen der Amerikaner reduziert werden sollten.
Ich meine, wenn jetzt irgendwie den Flughafen in Frankfurt, den militärischen
Teil oder so ein Standort wie Rammstein auflöst, da geht ja eine ganze Region
wirtschaftlich zugrunde.
Das ist ja dann sozusagen wie im Ruhrpott, wenn du auf einmal die Kohleproduktion einstellst.
Also es hat einfach nennenswerte, umfangreiche wirtschaftliche Folgen.
Es hat natürlich politische Folgen.
Und da sehe ich noch nicht, dass wir schon ausreichend bereit sind.
Immerhin, vielleicht können wir am Schluss auch noch mal kurz wieder in Richtung Ukraine schauen.
Das letzte Jahr waren es die Europäer, die am meisten dazu beigetragen haben,
dass die Ukraine sich verteidigen kann.
Das meiste Geld, die meiste Investitionen und vor allem natürlich der höchste
politische Support kam aus Europa.
Das hat jetzt nicht unbedingt immer reibungslos funktioniert und da gab es auch
viel Widerstände und politisches Hickhack hin und her, Aber im Großen und Ganzen
und Orban hin und her hat es doch halbwegs funktioniert.
Mittlerweile sind wir schon so weit, dass die Briten und die Franzosen darüber
diskutieren, ob man nicht mal Soldaten nach dem Krieg dauerhaft dort stationieren sollte.
Also man merkt, wie so langsam Schritt für Schritt die Debatte immer mehr in
eine Richtung geht, wo man sagt, wir müssen dafür sorgen, dass dieser Krieg beendet wird.
Wir werden das aber nicht auf dem Rücken der Ukrainer tun.
Selbstverständlich müssen die Russen sich komplett zurückziehen.
Es gibt da keine vollen Kompromisse und Russland darf nicht gewinnen und die
Ukraine muss gewinnen und wir gewinnen dabei alle. Das ist halt ehrlich das Ding.
Also ich bin auch der Meinung, wie ich in den letzten Sendungen dann auch schon
gesagt habe, mehrfach ist, Russland muss sich dieses Jahr was Neues einfallen lassen.
Also weiter so wie bisher geht nicht mehr für Russland und was sie sich einfallen lassen werden,
davon hängt halt dann ab, natürlich auch wie es weiter geht.
Aber auch ihr Spielraum reduziert sich, den die Russen haben,
politisch, finanziell und das reduziert.
Bringt halt Hoffnung plus, dass ja mittlerweile die Bevölkerung desillusioniert sind.
Also der Teil, der halt dem Kriegsgeschehen so ein bisschen folgt, der politisiert ist.
Es gab da jetzt auch Umfragen und Interviews, gerade wie denn so,
was denn so auf der Straße, Leute, was halten sie denn jetzt von Maduro.
Dass die Amerikaner den geholt haben.
Und die meisten Leute haben dann nicht gesagt, ja,
was tut Trump oder was für ein Skandal, sondern die meisten Leute haben dann gesagt,
ja, wir sind halt einfach schwach, wir werden halt zum Gespött der Welt,
wir verlieren halt einen Verbündeten nach dem anderen und können nichts tun
dagegen. Wir sind schwach.
Das war eine sehr häufige Reaktion, wie die Russen das gesehen haben.
Und wenn die Russen das Gefühl haben, also demoralisiert sind und sehen,
es geht in der Ukraine nicht vorwärts und in der Welt werden sie halt in den
Hintern und sonst wohin getreten immer wieder.
Und ja, also das kann man sagen, das sind vielleicht so zwei Lichtblicke, könnte man sagen.
Nicht die einzigen Lichtblicke, ich meine auch der wirtschaftliche Niedergang
der Russen wird sich in diesem Jahr beschleunigen.
Das hängt natürlich jetzt ein bisschen vom Ölpreis auch ab, wie sich das entwickelt.
Klar, weiß man nicht, aber derzeit entwickelt sich der Ölpreis in eine Richtung, nämlich nach unten.
Ja, das hatten wir auch beim letzten Mal, dass es eigentlich sein kann, also der Ölpreis,
Auf dem Weg nach unten ist halt ein Problem für Russland und ist ein Problem für Venezuela.
Selbst wenn der Ölpreis steigen würde, müsste Russland ja in der Lage sein,
davon nennenswert zu profitieren.
Und das sieht gar nicht gut aus.
Die Angriffe der Ukraine auf die Ölinfrastruktur sind massiv,
gehen immer weiter und werden sich tendenziell eher noch verstärken.
Speziell der Zugang zum Meer ist so eine Sache und ich kann mir auch sehr gut vorstellen,
dass wir in irgendeiner weiteren Eskalationsstufe vielleicht sogar sehen werden,
dass man den NATO-Leg schließt.
Und das ist vielleicht nicht unbedingt wahrscheinlich,
dass wir das jetzt in den nächsten Tagen sehen werden, aber das ganze Thema
hat auch ziemliches Eskalationspotenzial und who knows,
ich will keine Prognose darüber in den Raum werfen, wann dieser Krieg beendet ist.
Aber ich rechne damit, dass sich die Situation für die Ukraine in diesem Jahr
verbessern wird und für Russland verschlechtern wird.
Wie viel und wie sehr, das ist offen, aber das ist meine Erwartung auf Basis von allem.
Weil die Ukraine wird stärker, die Selbstversorgung auch mit Waffenmaterial steigt enorm an.
Der Druck auf Russland wird steigen, politisch steigen durch diese verlorenen Allianzen,
durch die katastrophale Wirtschaft, den niedrigen Ölpreis, der Druck jetzt auch
auf die Shadow Fleet und mal gucken.
Vielleicht ist ja mittlerweile Trump auch auf so einen Film angekommen,
dass er sich jetzt irgendwie auch mal gegenüber Russland mehr durchsetzen kann
und damit besser dasteht, weil das ist ja eigentlich das, woran er Interesse
hat. Das könnte schon eine ganze Menge bewirken.
Ja, also ja, die Gefahr einer Eskalation ist natürlich auch immer da,
wenn man mal überlegt, so vor 100 Jahren,
als zuletzt so dieses Spiel gespielt wurde mit den Imperien,
das hat dann ja zu zwei Weltkriegen geführt.
Im Moment sieht es nicht so aus, als wenn ein Weltkrieg kommen würde,
aber je nachdem, ich meine die Amerikaner haben halt Militär genug,
um sich quasi gegen den gesamten Rest der Welt eigentlich behaupten zu können,
zumindest, aber...
Ob tatsächlich dann der Wille und das Maß an Gleichschaltung in den USA dann
da sein wird oder eintreten wird, was man nicht hoffen kann.
Sehe ich jetzt erstmal den dritten Weltkrieg noch nicht kommen.
Weil der Einzige, der im Moment in der Lage wäre einzuführen, sind halt die USA.
Weil ich sage, die USA sind ungefähr genauso stark wie der Rest der Welt zusammengenommen.
In militärischer Hinsicht. Nur eben besser koordiniert und besser integriert und so.
Aber ja, also...
Wie gesagt, 2026 wird auf jeden Fall interessant und wir werden Änderungen sehen.
Wir werden Bewegung sehen in dem ganzen Krieg.
Davon bin ich überzeugt. Es ist nicht so, dass wir in zwölf Monaten hier sitzen
und sagen, das war jetzt eine Wiederholung des letzten Jahres mit kleiner Bewegungskrieg.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass das so weitergehen,
noch das ganze Jahr so weitergehen wird, sondern es wird zu Änderungen kommen
und für Russland sieht es nicht gut aus,
aber die Ukraine steht im Moment auch nicht rosig da.
Vor allem weil bei uns und in der EU der Groschen noch nicht so gefallen ist und noch nicht klar ist,
dass wir uns im Grunde genommen im Krieg befinden und mittlerweile jetzt ja
die letzten fünf Tage in Berlin schon aufgrund eines Terroranschlags 40.000
Leute für fünf Tage ohne Strom.
Warum das der Fall ist? Also erstmal bin ich davon überzeugt,
dass in irgendeiner Weise Russland mit dahinter steckt.
Sei es, dass sie halt Geld gegeben haben, sei es, dass sie indirekt oder sogar
direkt Leute instruiert haben, das zu tun.
Also ich denke schon, dass das nicht rein häuslicher Linksterrorismus ist oder so,
zumal diese Bekennerschreiben, was da passiert ist, ist auch irgendwie sehr bizarr.
Wobei was ich noch nicht verstanden habe und,
ich hoffe irgendjemand wird das aufklären am Ende des Tages aber wieso hat es fünf Tage gedauert und,
den Strom wieder herzustellen. Das verstehe ich.
Das kann ich dir sagen, das habe ich schon verstanden. Das ist wirklich nicht einfach.
Also bei dem Anschlag sind ja von den fünf Kabeln, die über die Brücke gegangen
sind, oder waren es vier, also auf jeden Fall, eine hat es überlebt. Glücklicherweise.
Kaputt gegangen ist halt die Versorgung für den südwestlichen Teil überlebt
hat es die Versorgung, die also auch über diese Kabelbrücke ging,
für den darüber liegenden nördlichen Teil.
Und das Problem ist, dass es sich dabei um Hochvoltleitungen handelt.
Also wirklich extrem viel Strom und sehr, sehr, sehr hohe Spannung tragende Kabel.
Die kriegst du nicht mal eben zusammengeführt, weil du kannst die nur fixen
unter Reinraumbedingungen zu nicht Freezing Temperatures, also wir haben jetzt
sozusagen auch nicht die richtige Temperatur.
Sprich, man musste da erstmal, um so etwas zu fixen, muss man das alles hermetisch isolieren.
Man muss das erstmal von den Schäden befreien.
Man muss dann die kaputten Kabel raustrennen.
Sowohl diese Kabel als auch die Muffen, mit denen man sowas reparieren kann,
liegen nicht einfach irgendwo rum. Das sind Spezialanfertigungen.
Und selbst wenn du die sofort griffbereit hast.
Da sind dann Ölmäntel, die müssen unter einem bestimmten Druck gehalten werden,
während man sie repariert.
Dann diese Muffen anzubringen, das braucht also Reinraumbedingungen,
da darf nicht ein Fingerabdruck eines Fingerabdrucks auf dem Kabel landen.
Wenn du danach die Spannung wieder anlegst, explodiert das Kabel sofort.
Also das ist sozusagen ohnehin etwas, was.
Noch lange dauern wird, bis die eigentlichen Kabel repariert sind.
Was sie ja gemacht haben, ist, dass sie diesen funktionierenden Teil und den
nicht funktionierenden Teil da eine neue Querverbindung gemacht haben,
um da die Stromversorgung wieder herzuholen.
Und auch das war eine sehr, sehr, sehr aufwendige Tätigkeit.
Also das ist tatsächlich etwas, was man sich eigentlich fragen muss,
ist, warum haben wir nicht sehr viel mehr redundante Zuschalleitungen,
um solche Querverbindungen an verschiedenen Stellen herzustellen,
um mehr Resilienz im Netz zu haben.
Aber das ist natürlich wie immer, also nach dem Schaden bist du immer etwas
klüger, aber unter den Voraussetzungen, die jetzt hier real da waren,
ist eigentlich die vergleichsweise kurze Zeit, die es jetzt gebraucht hat,
um dort wieder Strom hinzubekommen, schon eine Leistung.
Das ist sozusagen jetzt kein Versäumnis.
Das eigentliche Versäumnis ist unser kollektives Versäumnis,
dass wir unsere Infrastruktur nicht nur planen dürfen in puncto,
wie viel brauchen wir jetzt irgendwo, sondern was kann halt potenziell auch
kaputt gehen, wie viele Reserven haben wir in diesem Netz.
Also erstens hatten wir ja vor ein paar Jahren eine vergleichbare Situation
schon mal, wo es auch Tage gedauert hat. Das war dann in Köpenick.
Und da habe ich dem hinterher recherchiert und normalerweise ist es so,
dass es eigentlich keinen Single Point of Failure geben kann oder darf in so
einem vermaschten Stromnetz.
So ist eigentlich jeder Verbraucher oder jede von diesen Hochvoltleitungen,
da kommt Strom von beiden Seiten.
Kommen, wenn du verstehst, was ich Ich weiß.
Was du meinst, aber ich glaube in diesem Fall war es tatsächlich so,
dass diese Kabelbrücke relativ nah an der eigentlichen Stromquelle war und von
daher ist da Redundanz erstmal so nicht Naja.
Aber du hast dann einfach eine also normalerweise egal also sollte sein Stromnetz
und ist eigentlich auch so,
egal an welcher Stelle du jetzt ein Kabel durchtrennst es kommt von irgendwo
von der anderen Seite nochmal ein anderes Kabel.
Das kann man jetzt natürlich sagen.
Und in dem Fall von Köpenick damals war das wohl nur deshalb nicht gegeben,
weil man dabei war, gerade das umzubauen.
Weil die andere Trasse außer Betrieb war gerade und man temporär nur an einer,
Leitung jetzt hing. Also so.
Und als die dann kaputt war.
War auch das Backup sozusagen nicht verfügbar.
Also man lief das ohne, es lief ohne Backup so.
Und ich kann es nicht verstehen, wieso nachdem vor ein paar Jahren genau dasselbe passiert ist,
wieso man jetzt schon wieder so einen Single Point of Failure hat,
der zudem offensichtlich überhaupt nicht bewacht war so.
Also es ist mal wieder Berlin.
Es ist klar, jetzt wollen wir nicht in so einem Berlin-Rand hier enden.
Nicht, dass ihr nicht verdient wäre, aber es ist halt ein generelles Problem
mit unserer Infrastruktur.
Wir haben uns jetzt eine Wohlstandsinfrastruktur zugelegt und jetzt brauchen
wir halt eine Infrastruktur,
die eben potenziell auch so einem Terrorismus oder größeren Schäden durch Kriegseinwirkungen
gegebenenfalls auch besser standhält.
Nichts ist unverwundbar, vollkommen klar. Na gut, also...
High Note, ja, also ich fasse nochmal kurz zusammen.
Dinge werden sich bewegen. Unserer Meinung nach werden sie sich in die positive
Richtung bewegen, was die Situation jetzt in der Ukraine betrifft.
Europa muss weiterhin den Arsch noch mehr anheben, als das jetzt zumindest in
Ansätzen schon mal geschehen ist.
Die USA bleiben ein schwer zu berechnender Problempunkt und hat noch eine Menge
Potenzial, die Situation für alle unnötig zu verschlechtern.
Aber auch die USA ist nicht beliebig belastbar in der Hinsicht.
Da wird es einen gewissen Widerstand geben, inwiefern der sich am Ende dieses
Jahres in Wahlen niederschlägt, die dann hoffentlich auch noch richtig ausgezählt
werden. Das ist ja auch nochmal so ein Thema.
Das werden wir dann abwarten müssen.
Bis dahin müssen wir uns einfach vorbereiten. Aber Russland wird definitiv Ende
dieses Jahres nicht besser dastehen als jetzt, sondern wahrscheinlich deutlich schlechter.
Ich denke auch, genau. Problembär und Problemadler.
Ja, müssen wir damit klarkommen. Leute, das war es jetzt von uns,
unsere etwas längliche Zusammenfassung.
Das schon nach zwei Wochen nach der letzten Sendung.
Aber große Ereignisse müssen halt auch mal diskutiert werden.
Ja, das war es. Dann sagen wir vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Ja, macht's gut.
Bis bald. Musik.